bon c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
cata strophe là il ya un tournant et on
refermait à vivre mais dans une autre
direction c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité que pour sauver
des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais c'est une décision à
vraisemblable pour vous ça dépend quelle
valeur on attribuait la mort la vie
humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un départ
morales un débat éthique
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités toujours tenus à bonne
distance et nos reporters sur le terrain
l'actualité toujours dominé en partie
par les crises du coronavirus en france
et dans le monde
voici les titres l'hydroxyde chloroquine
est désormais interdite en france pour
traiter le coït 19
le décret l'autorisant a été abrogée
aujourd'hui par le gouvernement
une décision qui fait suite à l'avis
défavorable du haut conseil de la santé
publique saisie par le ministre de la
santé le professeur raoul lui précise
qu'il continuera à traiter ses passions
avec les traitements je cite les plus
adaptées à l'instar d'ailleurs de
plusieurs pays étrangers qui l'utilisent
déjà
[Musique]
la commission européenne propose un
fonds de 750 milliards pour relancer
l'économie des 27 est prouvé par
l'épidémie sa présidente ursula von der
leyen tape du poing sur la table et
appelle les européens à mettre leurs
préjugés de côté et à soutenir le projet
tout comme le fait la france
[Musique]
hong kong secouée par des heurts entre
forces de l'ordre et manifestants
un mouvement de rue qui s'opposent à un
projet de loi qui interdit l'outragé
l'hymne national chinois
une nouvelle loi sur la sécurité à hong
kong pourrait voir le jour demain à
pékin le parlement chinois doit
approuver cette nouvelle mesure de
sécurité nationale après les violentes
manifestations qui secouent l'archipel
depuis l'année dernière
[Musique]
l'hydro xi chloroquine n'est donc plus
autorisé en france pour traiter le
qu'ovide 19
le médicament a mis en lumière vous le
savez par le professeur out au début de
la pandémie pouvait être prêt ce qui
jusqu'ici à titre dérogatoire mais le
gouvernement en a décidé autrement après
un avis défavorable du haut conseil de
la santé publique est des essais
cliniques peuvent tout de même se
poursuivre de son côté le professeur
marseillais a fait savoir qu'il
continuerait à soigner avec les
traitements qu'ils estiment les plus
adaptées
lors du conseil des ministres olivier
ferrand a fait part de sa conversation
avec didier rahout écouter quand j'ai
posé la question aux professeurs à haute
et je crois qu'il a dit a répondu lui
même ya humanisation aujourd'hui il ya
quasiment plus le malade donc la
question de la chloroquine et lui
considère que la question la plus rock
il est derrière moi je considère qu'elle
n'est pas derrière nous parce que il
faut pouvoir se tenir prêt et si on
avait un traitement qui pouvait être
efficace et qui avait une augmentation
du nombre de malades qu'on puisse se
réserver la possibilité la possibilité
de le faire maintenant
il ya un cadre réglementaire qui définit
la possibilité ou non de prescrire un
médicament ce médicament dans cette
indication
comme d'autres médicaments dans d'autres
indications si un prescripteur
s'affranchit des règles
il prend entre guillemets ces risques et
alors que la france autorise n'autorise
plus l'hydroxyde chloroquine comme
traitement entre locaux vides 19
d'autres pays sont eux déterminés à
maintenir l'utilisation de cette
molécule et ce malgré les
recommandations contraires de l' oms
les précisions de syrie elle brouille la
controverse autour de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine se poursuit à travers le
monde
aux etats unis l'agencé du médicament
fda a choisi d'autoriser sa prescription
uniquement dans le cadre hospitalier
le traitement à titre préventif pris par
donald trump et lui proscrit alors que
l' oms a annoncé la suspension
temporaire de tous ses essais avec
l'hydro xi chloroquine le président
américain dit avoir arrêté son
traitement
avant cela ce dernier n'a eu de cesse de
défendre son utilisation tout au long de
la pandémie à jack layton l'hydroxyde
chloroquine est utilisé par des milliers
et des milliers de travailleurs de
première ligne pour qu'ils n'attrapent
pas cette horrible maladie ou peu
importe comment vous
les la plaie c'est un terrible virus
c'est quelque chose de terrible et
beaucoup de gens l'ont pris beaucoup de
médecins l'ont pris beaucoup de gens ne
jure que par ça est la chloroquine a
mauvaise réputation uniquement parce que
j'en parle je suis donc manifestement un
très mauvais promoteurs si quelqu'un
d'autre en faisait la promotion on
dirait que c'est la meilleure chose qui
soit mais étant donné que c'est moi coup
de tonnerre également au brésil où le
ministère de la santé a annoncé le
maintien de l'utilisation de ce
traitement
malgré les critiques de la communauté
scientifique brésilienne précision
étonnante l' usage de la molécule est
autorisé pour les patients légèrement
atteints à condition d'avoir une
prescription de leur médecin
la demande de chlorophylle et très
élevés nous pensons également qu'elle
est efficace
nous avons épuisé le stock jeune homme
n'en avons plus nous essayons de
chercher avec les distributeurs mais
c'est vraiment difficile pour nous d'y
parvenir car la demande pour ce
médicament est immense
malheureusement nous n'avons même pas
besoin de montrer pourquoi nous sommes
en rupture de stock maintien du
traitement également en algérie aucun
décès lié à l'usagé de cette molécule
n'aurait été enregistrés selon le
président du conseil de l'ordre des
médecins algériens un remède largement
répandue sur le continent africain
notamment au sénégal le pays qui aurait
enregistré des résultats concluants en
milieu hospitalier a confirmé ce
mercredi qu'il allait continuer à
traiter ces malades avec de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine sans émettre d'avis
contraire à son utilisation
le président macky sall prône à nouveau
les mesures de précaution déjà mises en
place au sein du pays nous devons rester
vigilants
nous devons poursuivre l'observance des
gestes barrières pour freiner la
propagation de la maladie
j'ai espoir qu'avec ses efforts continus
d'ici quelques moments nous pourrons
revenir petit à petit à la vie normale
la france est pour le moment le seul
pays d'europe à interdire l'utilisation
de l'hydroxyde chloroquine contre le coc
vite 19 l'essai européen discovery qui
testent actuellement plusieurs
traitements a annoncé avoir arrêté les
inclusions de patients destinée à
prendre ce médicament
parlez nous sommes avec violaine guerre
en immunologie ce collectif covit 19 les
deux sont les médecins à prescrire
bonsoir violemment
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france vous avez toujours défendu l'
usage la prise de ce médicament sur
notre antenne on a eu d'ailleurs un
débat récent houleux avec laurent
alexandre ici même
aujourd'hui ce médicament est interdite
en france jusqu'à nouvel ordre votre
réaction
écoutez j'irai dans le même sens crime y
sera autre que je ne connais pas je
précise mais par rapport à la réalité
actuelle du terrain c'est à dire que
nous ne voyons plus de patients atteints
de kovy deux à l'heure actuelle en
médecine libérale
donc par rapport à ce qui est notre
notre devoir de traiter des patients
avec un traitement efficace et qui a
clairement fait ses preuves pour les
gens qui ne sont utilisés parce que
c'est ça qui est important aussi c'est
de devoir l'expérience que les gens ont
de cette molécule de ce traitement du
traitement de l'asie trop misé une seule
également pour pouvoir donner un avis
éclairé
donc cette molécule va pas nous faire
défaut là la seconde près en revanche il
est clair que nous devons récupérer
cette liberté de prescription qui est
tout à fait indispensable et pense qu'il
peut peut-être nous tranquilliser c'est
que des études arrivent en phase précoce
avec ce traitement dhea aujourd'hui
aussi communiquer sur un une nouvelle
étude en cours de publication avec plus
de 3700 patients donc j'espère que
raison garder nous allons pouvoir ne
plus être bientôt le seul pays du monde
à interdire cette molécule dans le vide
et violaine guérin comment vous
expliquer aujourd'hui cette interdiction
c'est cette fameuse étude dont on a
beaucoup parlé paru vendredi
seul un set une étude très critique
envers cette molécule la faute donc à
cette étude vous pensez je pense que si
c'était humide et et analyser
sérieusement par l'état français il n'y
aurait aucune raison
d'interdire des drogues six taureaux
keane donc je pense qu'il ya des choses
qui nous dépassent et là je dirais que
moi je suis assez centré sur le choix et
que ça va peut-être peut-être avez-vous
justement les journalistes d'essayer de
comprendre ce qui se passe parce que la
situation est tout à fait surréaliste
l'étude est complètement biaisé lé
groupe ne sont pas comparables elles
émanent d'une base de données de de gens
qui sont essentiellement des
cardiologues et avec des des patients
qui ont des complications cardiaques
importante bien plus que dans la
population en standard on n'arrive pas à
savoir d'ailleurs qu'elle est la liste
des hôpitaux dans la caserne on a
récupéré des données les des
scientifiques ont fait la publication
n'ont pas vu un seul patient atteint de
deux co vide
il ya beaucoup de choses qui interpelle
en fait à votre connaissance puisque
vous le précisez bien en brousse et le
soin qui vous intéressent à votre
connaissance est ce qu'un patient a eu
des complications graves
après la prise diderot xi chloroquine
écoutez nous sommes plusieurs médecins
dans le collectif à avoir soigné des
patients comme cela avant le décret du
26 qui nous a empêchés d'avoir accès la
molécule nous avons tous été extrêmement
surpris de l'efficacité de ce médicament
qui a permis souvent un rétablissement
de l'état clinique extrêmement rapide et
je pense que tous les pays qui ont testé
cette molécule davo le joaillier dans
votre reportage en parlait du du brésil
eh bien je vois que les pharmaciens du
brésil sont en train de vivre des
ruptures pareil en france on a très peu
parlé de l'étude de brésilienne de
barbosa et collaborateurs qui sont des
médecins de terrain qui ont prescrit
extrêmement tôt cette association et qui
ont des eu d'excellents résultats c'est
ça qui explique que les pharmacies sont
vides au brésil j'étais aussi content de
voir par rapport à l'algérie la prise de
deux décisions des autorités algériennes
et dans le collectif nous avons un
pharmacien particulier d'algérie qui
nous renvoie des enfants
a sion donc il faut qu'on arrive à
comprendre effectivement ce qui ce qui
se passe dans ce pays sont les en jouant
les tics de l'aisne guérin quand on vous
écoute et quand on a vu le sujet
effectivement beaucoup de pays un
préconise même cette molécule sénégal
d'ailleurs décidé ce soir de continuer à
prescrire les drogueries chloroquine ça
veut dire quoi qu'il ya un principe de
précaution vraiment ont poussé à
l'extrême en france on a une spécificité
française rapidement parce que j'ai
d'autres questions à vous poser mais je
pense pas que ce soit du tout le
principe de précaution parce que c'est
totalement irrationnel et en plus si
c'était le principe de précaution
n'aurait pas restreint usage de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine avec le décret
du 26 mars aux patients les plus graves
parce que c'était précisément à eux
qu'il fallait pas ne pas la donner
donc il ya des choses qui ne sont
absolument pas scientifique en dessous
je ne sais pas quelles sont des intérêts
politiques économiques ou autres mais
sur le plan médical pur c'est n'est pas
normal c'est vrai qu'on parle beaucoup
d'intérêts financiers notamment les
laboratoires c'est quelque chose qui me
booste paraît pas saugrenue vous en tant
que médecin je pense que c'est
multifactoriel
je pense qu à l'évidence il ya des
intérêts de laboratoires et des intérêts
de l'om s puisque j'ai été confronté
avec une une responsable de l'om f sur
un sujet que je connais bien puisque
comme vous le dites j'ai des compétences
en immunologie où elle déclarait que le
coc des gens m'avaient pas cette
immunité que ce virus n'avait pas
permettre la formation d'anticorps
neutralisants et c'est ce qui est
vraiment n'importe quoi et d'ailleurs ça
se confirme entre autres avec les
données qu'on a élu hier pour la france
avec une très bonne immunisation des
soignants donc il ya de la
désinformation et dans quel but
voilà je pense que c'est multifactoriel
en plus ma dernière question elle
s'éloigne peut-être un deux de la
question justement des soins mais
évidemment on peut se la poser le
professeur out a émergé durant cette
crise sanitaire comme un
nouveau héros des anti système c'est
lui-même qui se positionne ainsi
opposants souvent le bon sens la
pratique faso aux constructions
intellectuelles des des élites est ce
qu'ils payent aujourd'hui en tout cas
vous savez ce sentiment il paye son
positionnement
moi je crois que monsieur raoult qu'il
est droit dans ses bottes
j'ai entendu effectivement son interview
il n'y a pas grand chose qui va pouvoir
qu'il veut le chambouler j'ai été très
intéressé d'entendre que à chaque fois
qu'il avait fait des découvertes
importantes et ne ce n'est pas la
première fois il avait toujours été
extrêmement shalit est donc pour lui ce
n'est qu'un chahut de plus et et parce
que ce qui est terrible pour moi c'est
pour les patients parce que je pense
qu'en france on aurait pu éviter des
morts je pense qu'on aurait pu
probablement évité de confinement de
toute une population
si on avait été prêt pour consignes et
des patients malades et pour faire les
tests et autres donc énormément de
traumatismes qui en sont des
conséquences est la gérante de
consultations toute la journée les
patients sont extrêmement perturbées par
ce qui s'est passé et avec des mêmes des
états dépressifs des angoisses et on n'a
pas fini de mesurer toutes les
répercussions de cette stratégie qui a
eu
merci beaucoup et lionel guérin
immunologiste d'avoir été avec mon
direct sur rt france l'assemblée
nationale approuve la mise en place de
la piste provident par 33 138 voix
contre 215 ce soir un moyen de traçage
numérique qui divise de son côté la cnil
elle avait déjà donné son feu vert pour
l application respecte la protection des
données
nous sommes en direct depuis l'assemblée
avec un autre reporter thomas bonnet
bonsoir thomas vous avez donc suivi la
séance au palais bourbon et ça y est le
vote est passé en tout cas pour
l'assemblée nationale oui après de longs
débats quatre heures environ des débats
très animés au sein de l'hémicycle les
positions étaient très tranchées parfois
et finalement donc le dispositif stop
coville a été approuvé par une majorité
de députés 338 se sont prononcés pour et
215 se sont prononcés
contre il ya beaucoup d' échange
d'arguments des arguments qui tournait
essentiellement autour de la notion de
liberté propose d'écouter un extrait de
l'intervention d'olivier ferrand
ministre de la santé qui s'est exprimée
donc à la tribune
à l'assemblée nationale il a été quelque
peu chahuté par certains députés je
propose d'écouter mais au nom de quoi
j'empêcherai tel ou tel député telle ou
telle personne de disposer de cet outil
de protection vous poser des questions
vous posez des questions qui sont
totalement légitime sur le plan éthique
est ce que est ce que cette application
est éthique est ce qu'elle est
liberticide com ou en temps sur les
bancs vous avez liberticide ça veut dire
privative de liberté en mon sens je
considère qu empêcher quelqu'un se doter
d'un outil qui permet de se protéger
ça c'est sans doute liberticide ça c'est
sans doute identique
moi je vais vous dire je veux avoir la
liberté je veux avoir la liberté demain
de télécharger ou de ne pas télécharger
une application pouvoir me protéger je
veux avoir la liberté de choisir dans
une semaine de l'enlever si je n'en veux
plus je veux avoir la liberté de pouvoir
être au courant avant pour m'appelle que
je suis potasse de protons seulement
qu'un contact et je veux avoir la
liberté de protéger encore débattre
éternellement et nous sommes là pour ça
pas éternellement mais en débattre parmi
les doutes exprimés par certains députés
de l'opposition il ya des doutes autour
de la pertinence de la mise en place
d'une application tels que stop commises
pour certains c'est trop tard et puis le
fait qu'elle ne soit pas obligatoire
pourrait peut-être menacé son efficacité
la question de l'efficacité de cette
application a d'ailleurs été très
souvent au coeur des débats cet après
midi à l'assemblée nationale question
aussi autour de la sécurité et des
données des utilisateurs alors la
ministre de la justice nicole belloubet
a tenté de rassurer dans un discours
préliminaire en expliquant qu'il n'y
aurait pas de fichage pas de
géolocalisation et que cette application
était téléchargeable que sur la base du
volontariat toutes les garanties ont été
prises pour respecter la vie privée des
français a déclaré nicole belloubet ce
n'a pas été en mesure de calmer les
oppositions des députés présents dans
l'hémicycle propose d'écouter
respectivement jean luc mélenchon député
la france insoumise et philippe gosselin
député les républicains tous les deux se
sont prononcés contre
puisqu'on a déjà des outils
en nombre important que l'état le
gouvernement peut déjà travailler
réellement et bien arrêtons la faisons
déjà avec les outils qui sont en notre
possession et le cas échéant tirons-en
les bilans et le moment venu
peut-être faudra-t-il rajouter autre
chose mais pour le moment il me semble
que tout est en ordre
et si on veut continuer à pouvoir le
dire comme on le fait ici en toute
sérénité bien il faut savoir dire stop
je fais partie de ceux qui ne veulent
pas qu'on sache près de qui j'étais à
moins d'un mètre pendant plus d'un quart
d'heure je ne veux pas un quart d'heure
et moi d'un mètre
c'est le temps d'un baiser de bien
d'autres applications je ne veux pas ça
ne vous regarde pas ni vous qui pensez
que ça ne saura pas quand même une fois
le ministre verront ici
il a dit ah mais on ne saura pas un
monsieur virant il vous reste à vivre
davantage pour savoir qu'on finit
toujours par savoir quand on ne veut pas
que ça se sache
en dépit donc de ces débats parfois
tendus la proposition a été approuvée
par une majorité de députés reste
maintenant l'étape du sénat ce soir
cette mise en place de l'application
stop qu'ovide sera discutée au sein du
sénat et si cela a été approuvé et bien
la mise en place de cette application
stop qu'ovide pourrait intervenir assez
tôt on parle d'une échéance d'ici ce
week end pour lancer l'application
officiellement m merci à thomas en
direct donc de l'assemblée nationale
edouard philippe présentera demain à 16
heures la phase 2 du déconfinement pour
réussir ce dernier le gouvernement
tablait sur 700 mille tests virologiques
par semaine à partir du 11 mai un
objectif difficile à atteindre alors
combien de tests existe-t-il aujourd'hui
sur le marché sont ils tous fiables
les précisions en images
[Musique]
son
/
[Musique]
et un nouveau test de dépistage du
coronavirus devrait être commercialisé
au mois de juin un test simple et rapide
par la salive baptisée easy coville a
été mis au point par un consortium
français pour en parler nous sommes avec
christophe carniel pdg de vaud gogos qui
a conçu un précisément le dispositif
numérique de ce dépistage à ses côtés
alexandre apprieu le jeune pdg de skill
celles qui développent par donc ces
tests de diagnostic de terrain bonsoir à
tous les deux merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france christophe carrière
et elle vous vous dirigez une pme
spécialisée dans le numérique appliquée
aux sports donc a priori rien à voir
avec le coronavirus quel est le rapport
avec ces tests qu'ovide pourquoi
comprennent oui bonsoir mais ravis
d'être avec vous oui en fait notre notre
industrie l'industrie du sport de
l'événementiel sportif a été mise à
l'arrêt avec le confinement et la
proximité de montpellier du laboratoire
6 de diag cnrs qui a mis au point pour
la recherche a mis au point le test
salivaire avec eux car le début du
confinement a démarré on a été sollicité
le laboratoire cnrs travaillait déjà
avec alexandre la société d'alexandra xl
pour transférer la technologie et pour
en faire un test salivaire il fallait un
complément numérique dont on fera
certainement parler à cette solution et
je trouve que la proximité
montpelliéraine des compétences dans le
domaine à la fois de la santé du
numérique ont fait que on est venu nous
chercher pour notre expertise dans le
traitement d'imagés alors alexandre
apprieu le jeune vous voulez vous allez
nous expliquer vraiment comment ça
marche
un mélange donc entre le numérique le
laboratoire du cnrs et vous-même donc en
quoi consiste ce nouveau texte
alors en fait la société skills elle est
une société qui est spécialisée dans le
développement de tests de terrain
donc c'est quelque chose en fait qu'on
faisait déjà avec le la
oratoire du cnrs et c'est vrai que quand
cette crise que vide est apparu on s'est
dit que nous pouvions mettre à profit
l'expérience que nous avions pour
développer un test de terrain cette fois
ci cette fois ci pour locaux vides donc
les développements ont été très rapides
en gros on a travaillé deux mois et demi
ce qui est terriblement cours pour notre
industrie
et le résultat c'est le test idy club
qui est un test salivaire a donc en fait
qui ou n'avez pas besoin de vous rendre
dans un laboratoire pour faire le
prélèvement la façon dont ça se passe
c'est extrêmement simple on prélève sous
la langue
un peu moins d'un mille litres de salive
on met cet échantillon successivement
dans deux tubes qui sont chauffés à 65
degrés le tout pendant une heure et au
bout d'une heure on a un résultat qui
est colorimétrique c'est à dire que si
le test est orange orange offre foncé
alors ça veut dire que le test est
négatif
et si le test est jaune vif cela veut
dire que le test est positif et donc
cette texture ans elle est possible à
l'oeil nu mais elle est également
possible via l'application qu'à
développer
christophe qui a bien d'autres
fonctionnalités et et c'est ce qui a
motivé notre collaboration
alors expliquez nous concrètement parce
qu'on a du mal à comprendre on est sur
le terrain on n'a pas besoin d'être en
labo en place une petite languette et
alors il n'y a pas de laboratoire on le
voit sur son iphone on voit le résultat
au bout d'une heure sur l'iphone comment
c'est possible je ne sais pas je laisse
celui qui est le plus à même de nous
expliqué christophe carniel peut-être
oui en fait comme le disait alexandra le
test il est réalisé d'abord
après le partenaire vraiment solidaires
et dans 2 éprouvette successives et la
particularité de ce test et qu'il et
colorimétriques voilà il ya un
changement de couleur et la vente un
changement des couleurs c'est qu'on peut
appliquer des techniques de traitement
du signal qui sont des techniques de
notre univers numérique
donc nous avons développé une
application qui vise dans les
dispositions du père du personnel de
santé de terrain donc qui va qui va
s'occuper du prélèvement et cette
application elle va lire numériquement
le résultat on déterminer si la personne
est positive aux copies de negative
beaucoup vite et à partir de là associé
à un système de gestion des données et à
une interopérabilité avec les systèmes
de santé existants mais on va pouvoir
envoyer ça sur un système d'information
de laboratoire
nous avons d'ailleurs le consortium a
annoncé qu'il était aujourd'hui ce matin
complété par un grand laboratoire de
biologie français qui le laboratoire a
innové
donc on va venir
communiquer aux systèmes d'information
du laboratoire le résultat du test
réalisé sur le terrain et ce résultat va
revenir validée par un médecin
biologiste au qu'effectivement il va
être officialisée comme le disait avec
son bras un peu moins d'une heure on va
faire tout le circuit qui permet du
direct depuis le terrain faire le test
les revenir sur le terrain avec les
résultats validés c'est en cela elle est
sandra a prié le jeune qu'il est
différent du test pcr qu'on connaissait
jusqu'ici avec les échos villon dans le
nez qui était peut-être plus laborieux
là c'est plus rapide tempête de terrain
voilà ou encore une fois on ne se
déplace pas le test bien non tout est
fait alors ya deux choses qui sont
différents que le premier c'est le type
d'échantillon leur traditionnellement
c'est vrai que pour le coc u19 on
faisait des prélèvements naso-pharyngés
nom très tôt on a fait le pari le pari
de la salle ivre jusqu'où se disait en
fait que la salive et est
potentiellement un bon vecteur de virus
et puis il était beaucoup plus
facilement accessibles alors depuis on a
un certain nombre d'études
internationales qui ont validé notre
choix donc on est assez on est assez
satisfait d'être parti dans cette voie
et vous parliez de la pcr
en fait le test on réalise c'est
également une pcr c'est à dire que comme
une et sert de laboratoire classique on
va détecter la rn du virus et on va
l'amplifier
mais la technologie que nous utilisons
qui s'appelle la techno lampe est une
technologie qui est différente de celle
qu'on utilise plus traditionnellement
laboratoire alors évidemment la question
que tout le monde se pose
on l'a vu dans le sujet précédent la
fiabilité interroge sur ces tests on
rappelle que le test pcr affiché 20 à 30
% de taux d'erreur qu'en est il du vôtre
alors moi je veux déjà insisté sur
quelque chose c'est que un élément dont
on a très peu parlé finalement dans les
médias c'est que la plupart des tests de
biologie médicale non pas une fiabilité
de 200% donc en cela le test de paix
sert de laboratoire ça n'est absolument
pas un mauvais tests à ses quelque chose
en fait qui est relativement classique
dans l'industrie donc il faut pas s'en
offusque
notre côté nous allons communiquer
l'ensemble des résultats de notre de
notre étude
vendredi matin c'est le cnrs et au chu
de montpellier qui vont le faire mais je
peux d'ores et déjà vous dire que nous
nous avons été contents des résultats et
que c'est pour ça que nous avons décidé
de lancer ce test y compris sur les
personnes asymptomatiques parce que j'ai
souvent là le problème
alors en fait ce qui est important pour
détecter le virage ses élèves le virus
c'est ce qu'on appelle la charge virale
donc ça ne dépend pas nécessairement
beaucoup de l'état du patient mais ça
dépend de la quantité de virus ans
christophe carniel vous avez reçu
l'agrément quand est-ce que ce texte
sera commercialisé parquet ou pourra qu
il se trouvait et comment ça va marcher
tout cela alors que la certification le
marquage europe est prévue pour la
première quinzaine de juin
la commercialisation elle va se faire
soit directement depuis par la société
skills elle soit par des laboratoires de
biologie dori nori
c'est l'objet du partenariat que nous
avons annoncé ce matin à l'idée étant
que on est une une logistique complète
un dispositif complet intégré qui permet
d'aller au départ de grands moyens de
transport par exemple pour tester les
gens avant qu il monte dans un avion en
train ou un bateau allait à l'entrée des
espaces et ça ça nous intéresse beaucoup
chez vos goûts puisque notre
contribution a lui aussi fait pour qu'on
redémarre notre industrie du sport donc
aller tester des clubs par exemple pour
que les sportifs puisqu'il reprendre
l'entraînement et rapidement les mii
casadesus à huis clos alors à moyen
terme bien sûr ce qui nous intéresse
c'est que il ya le public qu'ils
puissent revenir dans les stades
donc l'idée c'est de pouvoir faire un
dépistage massif à l'entré deux
lieu où du public est attendu donc voilà
c'est aussi pour cela que nous on s'est
engagés dans ce processus
la commercialisation allez faites par le
consortium avec ce qu'il sait en prime
contractor et bien sûr des distributeurs
comme lino vie avec ce qu'on a annoncé
aujourd'hui le schéma pour à son se
répéter dans les pays européens on
espère un peu au delà dans les semaines
à venir
alexandre a prié le jeune dernière
question c'est que le gouvernement
français un petit peu si j'ose dire
familièrement galéré pour fournir les
708 est promis vous vous allez réussir
en produire beaucoup de vos tests
oui c'est davantage un petit peu notre
technologie puisque en fait nous avons
besoin de très très peu de réactifs
donc nous travaillons avec la société
efira liste qui est en alsace et qui va
produire nos tests est d'ores et déjà la
société finalis nous dit que dès
maintenant elle peut produire 200 mille
tests par semaine et c'est une
production que si si nécessaire elle
peut largement 21
merci en tout cas à tous les deux et bon
vent à votre texte christophe carniel
alexandra brieuc prieux le jeune d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france il
est 20h30 soyez les bienvenus si vous
nous rejoignez et 20h30 heure française
une europe éprouvent et donc par le cos
vite 19 mai pourtant très divisé les 27
ont ils réussir à mettre leur désaccord
de côté et accepter le plan de relance
proposé par la commission européenne
aujourd'hui les précisions de grégoire
dont seul et c'est peu avant midi que
paolo jane thilo ni le commissaire
européen aux affaires économiques et
monétaires a vendu la mèche dans un
tweet
l'italien a annoncé le montant global
des aides qui seront accordées aux 27
états membres de l'union
la commission propose un fonds de
relance de 750 milliards d'euros en plus
des instruments commun déjà lancé une
percée aux européennes pour faire face à
une crise sans précédent
la présidente de la commission
européenne a appelé l'europe à
outrepasser les divisions
les crises situation en grèce souri à
yann thesse mettant de côté les vieux
préjugés ils redécouvrent ont plutôt le
pouvoir qui est basé sur l'idée d'une
europe comme une dita von teese à
grossemy des annonces comme miles à la
crise à laquelle nous devons faire face
aujourd'hui est énorme mais
l'opportunité pour l'europe est notre
responsabilité sont tout aussi énorme
pour faire ce qu'il faut dans cette
situation et 10 titres actions dasri
chic de soutou l'espagne et l'italie
devraient se partager une grosse part du
gâteau elle la commission européenne
prévoyant d'allouer plus de 40% des
fonds rien co2 péninsule la france quant
à elle ne devrait percevoir qu'à peine
39 milliards d'euros un plan
immédiatement soutenue par rome et paris
excellent signal de bruxelles
il va dans la direction indiquée par
l'italie nous avons été décrits comme
des visionnaires parce que nous y avons
cru dès le début 500 milliards d'euros
de subventions et 250 milliards de prêts
est un montant adéquat accélérons les
négociations et des blocs ont les
ressources rapidement j'aurais
essentielle pour l'europe
ursula von der leyen propose un plan de
relance inédit de 750 milliards d'euros
pour les régions et secteurs en
difficulté l'accord franco-allemand a
permis cette avancée
nous devons aller vite et adopter un
accord ambitieux avec tous nos
partenaires européens
le partage de la dette reste un sujet
épineux dans les discussions en effet
les quatre frugaux que sont les pays-bas
l'autriche le danemark et la suède sont
hostiles à l'idée de participer
davantage au budget européen
outre les aides destinées aux pays et
secteurs dans l'urgence le plan devrait
prévoir des investissements dans des
sphères jugé clés comme le numérique et
la transition verte et pour en parler
nous sommes avec l'autre blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
bonsoir claude à blanchemaison merci
d'être avec nous
ursula von der leyen présidente de la
commission européenne s'est elle révélée
aujourd'hui avec son plan de relance
je crois qu'on peut le dire parce que
s'il a indiqué m.poutine nouvelle
commission depuis le 1er novembre et
elle se pouvait plonger dans la
tourmente de la pandémie puis ensuite de
la crise économique provoquée par cette
folie et par les mesures de confinement
tri de l'état n'en est effectivement
elle a réagi dans le court avec beaucoup
d'intelligence puisque elle a pris la
proposition franco-allemande et ali a
ajouté la proposition d easy go les
pays-bas l'autriche le danemark et la
semaine donc des dons et des prêts et
anne après un accueil et qui est tout
autant que les ja neuro alors
[Musique]
claude blanchemaison sont obligés et
malheureusement n'interrompe notre
client sont pour un problème de son va
peut-être réussir à arranger ça dans
quelques secondes non me dit on pour
l'instant on va poursuivre le déroulé
donc c'est de cette émission si vous
comptez traversée en tout cas une
frontière au cours des prochains jours
attention le trajet pourrait être plus
difficile que prévu les états s'adapte à
la pandémie avec des mesures en
constante évolution depuis quelques
semaines c'est bien sûr le cas en france
les explications en images
[Musique]
le secteur aérien en crise dans le monde
entier l'épidémie de kobe de 19 a obligé
de nombreuses compagnies à clouer sa
flotte au sol pendant plus de deux mois
une catastrophe pour les entreprises
dont certaines ont déjà annoncé leur
faillite les précisions en images
[Musique]
et
et nous revenons sur ce plan qu'a
proposé la présenter préférant présenter
plus tôt la présidente de la commission
européenne
aujourd'hui claude blanchemaison nous
vous retrouverons avec le sont cette
fois-ci nous disions que c'était
vraiment révélé un ursula von der leyen
avec la présentation de ce plan de
relance aujourd'hui
oui d'accord je crois qu'elle a imposé
ce plan aux commissaires qui constitue
le collège de compagne six autres
commissaires que l a présenté
aujourd'hui au parlement européen et que
l'accueil a été dans l'ensemble très bon
sauf peut-être à l'extrême droite
maintenant évidemment les choses
sérieuses commencent puisqu'il va
falloir aller vers les états membres et
là je pense que madame van der leyen de
la vienne je gros jeu parce que ou bien
ça passe
et à ce moment là elle ras on
reconnaîtra comme une véritable femme
d'état puisque c'est l'expression qu'il
faut utiliser ou bien les états membres
n'arrivent pas à se mettre d'accord et à
ce moment là on l'accusera d'avoir vu
trop grand et de ne pas avoir tenu assez
suffisamment compte de l'opinion des
états du nord donc je pense que l a eu
ce courage de faire cette proposition
aujourd'hui jacques delors l'avait un
peu mise au pied du mur en disant il ya
quelques semaines
s'il n'y a pas une action de solidarité
et bien c'en est fini de l'union
européenne rien que cela est en effet le
marché unique comme le euro pourrait
être menacé
le prénom de l'anc maison en quoi ce
plan est t'il inédit il est inédit parce
que pour la première fois on utilise le
crédit financier delà de la commission
européenne pour l'autoriser à faire un
gigantesque emprunt sur les marchés
financiers 750 milliards d'euros c'est
évidemment et d'armes et jusqu'à présent
notamment ne souhaitait pas que la
commission européenne se lance dans ce
genre d'exercice il y avait un budget
qui a été voté en équilibre et qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas avoir des déséquilibres
qui par conséquent ne pouvait pas donné
lieu à des emprunts
deuxièmement le élément nouveau c'est
effectivement que avec une partie de cet
emprunt la plus grosse partie 500 il y a
eh bien
la commission va faire des subventions à
des programmes présentés par les états
membres pour aider les secteurs où les
régions les plus affectées par la crise
et puis qu avec les 150 millions
restants eh bien elle va faire des prêts
également aux états membres ou dans tout
cas certains d'états membres pour qu'ils
le puissent prêter cet argent au secteur
et aux régions les plus affectées alors
la dernière rangée originalité c'est que
le remboursement de ce set enfin il va
être budgété dans le budget de l'union
européenne et bien le remboursement sera
fait par les états membres en fonction
de la clé traditionnelle de financement
des budgets ce qui veut dire que on ne
changera pas la culée l'allemagne par
exemple des finances budget environ 26%
et bien devoir rembourser 26 % la france
17%
quelles que soient les sommes reçues
dans le cadre des dons ou des prêts
qu'elles seront les contreparties alors
les contreparties y en a plusieurs
d'abord le fait que naturellement les
états dits frugaux les d'état rigoriste
vent évidemment exigé que ceux qui
veulent déficit de dons ou de prêts
s'engage à faire des réformes
structurelles puisque leur thèse c'est
que si ces états sont en mauvaise
situation économique
c'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas fait
suffisamment de réformes structurelles
dans le passé et il faut donc les faire
or évidemment l'italie et l'espagne
considère qu'il s'agit d'un traitement
d'une situation d'urgence et que elles
ne veulent pas se mettre sous une
tutelle quelconque justin de bruxelles
donc c'est une première difficulté
la deuxième difficulté c'est que
évidemment c'est cet emprunt va être
budgété il va donc falloir remonter au
moins temporairement la limite qui est
actuellement assignée au coach union
européenne 1,2 pour cent du pib et la
commission va proposer de le remonter à
2 % certains états sont réticents même
si c'est
une période transitoire et puissant il
va falloir rembourser cet emprunt et la
commission laissent un peu le sujet
ouvert puisque elle dit de toute façon
nous rembourserons entre 2028 et de 1058
donc on a le temps de discuter des
modalités avec les états membres et
peut-être que l'on peut disent ils à
mettre en place de nouvelles ressources
propres au budget communautaire
par exemple une taxe carbone par exemple
une taxe sur les grandes entreprises
numériques alors peut-il y avoir un club
dans une maison à un accord entre les
différents états il faut être très
optimiste pour penser qu'il y aura un
accord au conseil européen du 18 et du
19 juin prochain à à bruxelles
ce conseil européen devra être non pas
par vidéoconférence
comme le précédent mais probablement
avec la présence physique parce que ça
va être très difficile
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement et
chacun fera valoir son point de vue
alors c'est d'autant plus compliqué que
parallèlement à ce que nous venons
d'évoquer
il y assure la table la discussion sur
un cadre budgétaire à 7 11 pour l'union
européenne pour lequel la commission
propose que un milliard cent 100
millions d'euros ce qui correspond à peu
près à la projection du coach actuel on
était puis par sept et on obtient à peu
près ceci simplement les états du nord
ou la réduire les fonds consacrés à la
politique agricole commune et voulait
réduire les fonds structurels qui
servent donc pour la petite agricole
commune essentiellement aux états
méditerranéens europe et de l'ess et
puis pour les fonds de cohésion
également beaucoup au pays de l'est
hélas la france naturellement à se
battre pour qu'on ne touche pas à la
politique agricole commune et les pays
de l'est si on se bat pour qu'on ne
touche pas aux fonds de cohésion
je me demande si d'ailleurs la solution
la plus simple ne serait pas d'essayer
d'avoir un accord sur les grandes lignes
du plan de relance de ce qui a été
présenté aujourd'hui comme plan de
relance est renvoyé à l'automne
la discussion sur le cadre budgétaire
pluriannuel merci prod blanche raison
d'avoir été avec nos experts en
relations internationales
on en vient à présent ces nouvelles
manifestations à hong kong un important
dispositif policier a dispersé les
opposants à pékin réunis autour du
parlement local
ils protestaient contre l'examen d'un
projet de loi criminalisant tout outrage
à l'hymne national chinois
la semaine dernière pékin avait déjà
décidé d'instaurer une nouvelle loi sur
loi sur la sécurité dans le territoire
autonome et détails avec françois xavier
lambert le coeur de hong kong à nouveau
plongé dans le chaos sous les yeux des
journalistes les policiers multiplient
les tirs de gaz poivre pour disperser
des centaines de manifestants
les opposants au pouvoir perçu comme
trop pékin dénonçant projet de loi
criminalisant tout outrage à libre de
national chinois au délit qui serait
passible de trois ans de prison
les manifestants se disent déterminés à
faire entendre leurs revendications
les gens ont le droit de manifester et
de venir au rassemblement
donc je pense que c'est vraiment un abus
de pouvoir que de bloquer toutes les
assemblées pacifique et toutes les
demandes de rassemblements ces
manifestations surviennent alors que le
parlement local recommence aujourd'hui
l'examen de ce projet de loi
la situation est suivie attentivement
par les états unis déjà engagés dans une
guerre économique avec la chine des
sénateurs se sont déjà dits prêts à
prendre de nouvelles sanctions contre
pékin
de son côté donald trump a implicitement
menacé la chine de priver au compte de
son statut économique spéciale c'est
quelque chose dont vous allez entendre
parler avant la fin de la semaine de
manière très intense je pense la
pression américaine ne semble pas
atténué la détermination chinoise de
mettre un terme à l'agitation qui secoue
le territoire semi autonome depuis
plusieurs années début mais pékin a
renforcé son influence au parlement hong
kong et des élus proches du gouvernement
chinois ont ainsi pris le contrôle du
comité de la chambre
une commission chargée de passer en
revue les projets de loi avant leur
examen
l'inquiétude des opposants s'est aussi
renforcé la semaine dernière à la suite
de la décision d'imposer à hong kong
nouvelle loi sur la sécurité nationale
officiellement le texte vise à combattre
le terrorisme et les ingérences
étrangères dans le territoire semi
autonome
mais il permettra surtout à pékin
d'implanter légalement sa police secrète
à hong kong
le texte devrait être adopté ce jeudi
par l'assemblée nationale populaire
chinoise et pour en parler nous sommes
avec heijningen longue journaliste
consultant bonsoir oui mes amis nous
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france en compte quel est l'état
d'esprit qui prédomine aujourd'hui la
colère la peur je pense qu'il ya quelque
chose d'être très spontanée après donc
sachant que l'oeil à la pandémie qui
s'est mêlée tout ça que ça s'était
arrêté pendant quelques mois je pense
qu'il ya quelque chose de spontané et de
beaucoup moins organisé qu'il pouvait y
avoir auparavant
donc là tous les mouvements qu'on a vu
ces derniers jours sont des sondés
mouvement plutôt paisible et et spontané
qui ce qui se déroule de manière on va
dire assez disparate nous ont organisé
beaucoup moins soumis à beaucoup moins
d' influence qu'auparavant extérieur
donc l'état d'esprit est vraiment dans
l'expectative et puis surtout dans la
avec beaucoup de surprise également
parce que comment dire jusque-là pékin
s'était montré extrêmement comment dire
a montré beaucoup de mansuétude envers
le mouvement démocratique de hong kong
est aujourd'hui on voit qui durcit le
ton que on était surpris même que pékin
ne le fasse pas plus tôt là aujourd'hui
on voit un vrai une véritable volonté de
changement de stratégie et surtout
d'avoir la mainmise sur ces mouvements
le hong kong et les six possibles les
pertes heures et justement pour quelle
raison comment vous vous l'expliquer qui
est moins peut-être de tolérance
désormais ce changement de stratégie
je m'explique pas tant ce cette moindre
tolérance que cette comme je voulais les
dix sept grande mansuétude qui était
observé auparavant par rapport à ces
manifestations c'est à dire que quand
même par rapport aux nombres de
d'événements de manifestation qui a eu
avant
avant la pandémie il ya eu très peu de
victimes les lélés la police comme a été
très moment délicate on va dire par
rapport aux manifestants même s'il ya eu
des débordements mais bon il y avait
tellement de faction en accédant à ce
moment-là qu'il était qu'elle aurait été
difficile de démêler qui fait quoi là
aujourd'hui on voit qu'il ya quelque
chose qui vaut davantage réfléchi et
surtout politiquement parce que ces
annonces la ne vienne bientôt un moment
où on qu'on va bientôt certainement dans
les jours qui viennent
rouvrir les boîtes de nuit les bars et
chose ce genre de lieu mais aussi mettre
fin par exemple à la quarantaine pour
les gens qui arrivent à hong kong
donc en même temps qu'on va rouvrir
lille on va serrer la vis en quelque
sorte au à ses habitants et sachant que
aussi que le que la date de vote de
cette loi sur l'eau nationale entame sur
le sol hymne national sur le trajet à
nîmes a été choisie de manière
extrêmement stratégique puisqu'il aura
lieu le 4 juin soit la date anniversaire
de tiananmen ce qui veut dire que les
gens ne pourrons pas manifester ce
jour-là
justement qu'est-ce que ça dit parce que
c'est pas anodin vous l'avez dit outrage
voilà aline ça dit quoi justement ça dit
enfin évidemment on joue sur les
symboles il faut bien tenir compte des
de la culture locale là on va se servir
d'un symbole pour exprimer toute une
batterie de mesures qui effectivement
seront davantage répressive
c'est à dire que on a on a vu un avant
avant l'épidémie il y avait de la gueule
outrage au drapeau il y avait là des ses
créations de pendant la profanation de
deux drapeaux part dans cet anglicisme
il y avait beaucoup de gestes dans ce
sens-là des drapeaux chinois a brûlé des
drapeaux américains ben dis donc tous
les symboles qui pourrait être contre
qui pourrait aller à l'encontre de pékin
pour être davantage maîtrisée donald
trump lui est intervenu il promet une
riposte ici la fin de la semaine et
évoque une réaction très puissante
comment interpréter ces propos du
président
américains et que doit-on attendre on
peut en attendre pas beaucoup de bien
malheureusement parce que on conduite
d'un statut particulier
donc par rapport aux commerces notamment
donc étant que selon les traités 1997
tant que ce cessez tant que une certaine
autonomie de lille est respecté par
pékin et bien hong kong us et d'un
statut particulier pour le commerce
international
donc ce qui se passe c'est que donald
trump pourrait remettre en question ce
traité et l'assimiler à la chine et je
sais ce qui serait bien ce serait
extrêmement dommageable évidemment au
relais hong kong est et c'est un peu ça
le problème c'est que sont les hong kong
et qui vont s'offrir dans que tâche que
pékin ait un gosse mais allons comme si
c'est minuscule par rapport à part à la
chine mais le collatéral aussi c'est que
la balance commerciale entre les états
unis et hong kong est plutôt très en
faveur des états unis donc le commerce
américaine s'offrir également et
justement mac pompéo a déjà annoncé un
petit peu là la couleur aujourd'hui un
selon lui on comble juil public ne jouit
plus de l'autonomie promise vis-à-vis de
pékin et donc ne peut par conséquent
continuer à bénéficier de privilèges
commerciaux avec les états unis comment
on interprète ses propos chez vous là je
ne pourrais pas parler pour tout le
monde mais je suis activités de paris je
suis à l'écouté de ce qui se passe en
tête dont des chinois de hong kong votre
famille
évidemment vous connaissez voilà comment
la situation mais n'étant pas sur place
le jour j c'est à dire que ça a été ça
c'est allé très vite un tir déneigement
tout s'est passé en à peu près en même
temps je ne sais pas vraiment comment
les gens réagissent là bas je pense
qu'il ya certaines attentisme il ya il
ya beaucoup de beaucoup de gens
regardent quand même les états unis
parce qu'il ya de l'espoir
derrière il ya ces mouvements
démocratiques qu'on loue pas on est
d'accord ou pas mais on sait que ils
attendent beaucoup des forces de
l'occidental de faire quelque chose pour
les aider à accéder à une chose parce
qu'en fait tout les autres
revendications disparu aujourd'hui
au départ c'était la tradition bill et
après il ya plein de choses qui sont
arrivées aujourd'hui c'est devenu
beaucoup plus clair aussi bien du côté
de pékin que du côté de roncq on sait
que les gens veulent l'indépendance de
rencontre et forcément ça ne plaît pas à
pékin
merci wyoming à l'ong d'avoir été avec
nos journalistes consultants hong kong
et un chinois de hong kong comme ça vous
vous présentez vous étiez en direct
effectivement de paris merci à vous
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de la grève des loyers
dans un immeuble de bagnolet en
seine-saint-denis avec la crise du coc
vie des familles sont confrontées à de
graves difficultés financières et à la
spéculation liée au futur grand paris
et puis nous continuerons de parler de
ce département le département le plus
pauvre de france qui en dépit de ses
nombreuses à tour est plongé dans une
profonde crise sociale et économique on
tentera d'y voir plus clair avec nos
invités dans notre face à face
[Musique]
l afrique et compte 1 % de cas dans le
monde sait très peu comment vous
l'expliquez nous devons considérer que
les chiffres sont sous-estimés mais nous
ne sommes pas encore au niveau où se
trouve par exemple l'europe ou les états
unis
quelle stratégie vous avez déployés dans
le sud kivu pour limiter la propagation
du virus on a proposé à ce qu'est le
confinement puisse être sélectif est
concerné seulement des personnes âgées à
haut risque de complication pour
sensibiliser la population
ça l'est beaucoup plus facilement
puisqu'elle venait de sortir d'une d'une
épidémie d'ebola qui exige également la
distanciation social lavage des mains
qui était si on aura affaire à deux
épidémies aussi dangereuse qui est des
mollahs et coronavirus ça pourrait être
très très difficile pour nous on vit
tous les jours sans faire attention que
tout en dépend c'est l'unité de mesure
de toute chose une convention admise par
tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on fait combien on reste traumatisée
mais on cherche en soi et autour de
soins quels sont les facteurs qui vont
nous permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et la faune talent de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
cata strophe là il ya un tournant et on
se remet à vivre mais dans une autre
direction
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines la moitié de la
planète
jamais on a fait simple jamais plaint
d'une décision invraisemblable pour vous
ça dépend telles valeurs on attribuait
la mort la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas c'est un débat n'aura
un débat éthique
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques et sur ces sujets sensibles
je vais vous partagez mon internat dans
la crise du coc vite 19
c'est toute une chaîne décisionnelle
médicales administratives et politiques
et responsables du fiasco
alors que l' oms recommandait le port du
masque par les populations la parole
publique a longtemps menti sur sa
nécessité pour ne pas avouer la triste
absence du stop requis la décision de
confinement s'imposait compte-tenu du
manque de matériel permettant d'autres
solutions mais en freinant l'hécatombe
on pénalise les connaît l'état ne pourra
plus est l'état providence que nous
avons que pour anne aura été cimetière
de certaines espérances en pensant que
progrès peser de nous des hommes dieu et
que les technocrates avec les du monde
de demain les conséquences de la crise
oblige à repenser nos modèles la
découverte du télétravail l'intérêt de
consommer des produits locaux le besoin
de solidarité vont faire évoluer une
population qui a découvert qu'elle était
mortel
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
est-ce qu'on a une idée d'augmentation
ou pas des signes ici d'aujourd'hui en
france les causes et les violences
existait avant leur confinement
et pendant ce compliment c'est vrai
qu'il ya sept ce cadre l'état sur les
taux des féminicides a plus que je dis
pas doublé mais bien monté
forcément on n'a pas encore tous les
chiffres officiels c'est très difficile
bourreau n'est jamais n'est jamais loin
finalement c'est le confinement dans le
confinement
cela veut dire qu'il ya huit clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément dans les femmes victimes de
violences de nombreux repas à 3
[Musique]
demain
bonsoir à tous personne nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi 27 mai à bagnolet en france une
grève des loyers prével la précarité de
locataires touchés par la crise du
coronavirus 21 une famille d'un immeuble
du parc privé réclame une diminution de
leur loyer la seine saint denis
département le plus pauvre de france et
fragiliser encore un peu plus par cette
crise sanitaire
alors pourquoi ce département situé aux
portes de paris sony style alors qu'il a
tous les atouts pour décoller ce sera
l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
la libye est à nouveau au coeur des
tensions selon les états unis moscou
aurait déployé des avions chasse pour
soutenir des mercenaires au sol
combattant aux côtés du maréchal khalifa
haftar accusations démenties par la
russie l'homme fort de l'est libyen mène
depuis plus d'un an une offensive visant
à s'emparer de tripoli à l'ouest siège
du gouvernement d'union nationale
reconnue par l'onu
[Musique]
depuis l'apparition de la pandémie due
coronavirus plusieurs théories du
complot et sème les réseaux sociaux et
font le tour du monde
la faute tantôt aux juifs tantôt aux
musulmans locaux vides 19 n'a jamais
existé où il a été créé en laboratoire
ou par le gouvernement chinois à chacun
sa théorie sont explications farfelues
une étude britannique s'est penché sur
les conséquences de ces informations de
ce que pourraient avoir ces fausses
informations
[Musique]
depuis fin avril 21 une femme ni
locataire d'un immeuble du parc privé de
bagnolet réclame une diminution de leur
loyer en raison d'une hausse des charges
durant confinement elles ont unanimement
décidé de suspendre le paiement à leurs
propriétaires et précision de renault
parquet avec charles beaudry et jordi
demory revenu 0 loyer 0 c'est le slogan
d'une des banderoles accrochées à la
façade d'un immeuble à bagnolet en
seine-saint-denis depuis la fin du mois
d'avril les habitants de cette résidence
privée et tire la sonnette d'alarmé avec
le confinement ils sont nombreux à
connaître des difficultés financières
dans ce contexte de chômage partiel et
de baisse de revenus l'augmentation des
charges durant le confinement a fait
bondir les locataires on a donc envoyé
un courrier fin avril pour du coup
alerté sur cette situation on a créé un
comité
un comité des locataires donc avec le
soutien de droit au logement
l'association dal pour justement un peu
faire face à cette situation et donc on
a envoyé un courrier pour expliquer un
petit peu l'ensemble des d une chose
qu'on avait identifiées qui nous
paraissaient problématique à la fois
donc effectivement le l'idée d'un
moratoire sur les loyers mais aussi tous
les dysfonctionnements
donc voilà on a envoyé cette fin avril
on a proposé en fait aux bailleurs de
venir nous rencontrer
pour en discuter la réponse qui nous a
été faite c'était que effectivement avec
les règles de confinement c'était
compliqué et donc nous on fait un
courrier de retour reprenant point par
point et voilà mais on espère toujours
pouvoir les rencontrer rapidement pour
pouvoir évoquer cette situation
outre les loyers les charges les
habitants de l'immeuble ont voulu aussi
attiré l'attention sur les
détériorations dans certains
appartements fuite d'eau mauvaise
isolation problèmes de ventilation
les griefs sont nombreux là donc il ya
deux séries de studio un rez-de-chaussée
ou en rez-de-chaussée bas donc
rez-de-chaussée bas très clairement ils
sont enterrés ce sont les fenêtres là et
ici c'est la sellor cloisons quoi c'est
cesser leurs murs donc c'est pas du tout
isolé c'est du métal pas et ils sont pas
isolés donc j'ai toute une histoire de
vmc de chaudières ils n'ont ni le
chauffage ni la vmc n'y aucune
enfin je veux dire il n'ya pas
d'isolation rien du tout donc ils
prennent toutes les midis tu es donc
l'hiver même si on n'a pas des hivers
sibériens franchement le quand il fait
très humide et c'est terrible depuis la
lettre envoyée aux bailleurs quelques
travaux ont été effectués mais la
situation de cet immeuble n'est qu'un
exemple parmi tant d'autres en france
l'état a injecté 110 milliards d'euros
dans l'économie il a rien mis sur le
logement c'est atterrant
c'est à dire que derrière on risque
d'avoir à partir de l'année prochaine
c'est une bombe sociale qui s'annonce
avec des dizaines de milliers
d'expulsions supplémentaire des gens qui
vont se retrouver à la rue on risque de
se retrouver dans la situation qu'on a
connue aux états unis ou en espagne
après la crise des subprimes en 2009 où
c'est des millions d'oeuvres de ménage
quand t'es foutu dehors
est ce que c'est ça qu'on veut en france
non ça je pense que on doit mettre en
place ses filets de sécurité d'une part
mettre en place un fonds d aide aux
impayés de loyers conséquents de
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
voire un ou deux milliards d'euros
il faut suspendre les sanctions pour à
l'encontre des locataires qui ont des
difficultés de paiement
il faut suspendre l'expulsion effective
et jusqu'à l'année prochaine
après on verra et enfin il faut agir
mener une politique efficace de lutte
contre le logement cher c'est-à-dire
encadrer les loyers plus taxés durement
les profits spéculatifs
le confinement à augmenter la précarité
de locataires touchés par la crise du
coronavirus un contexte difficile qui
s'ajoute à la tensions spéculatives aux
abords des gares du grand paris qui
semble donc se poursuivre et pour
évoquer cette situation en bagnole et
nous sommes avec l'une de ses habitants
de l'immeuble on a d'ailleurs vu dans le
reportage hélène roger bonsoir madame
merci d'être avec nous d'avoir accepté
de témoigner en direct sur rt france
vous fait donc partie de ces familles
qui font la grève des loyers est ce que
ça a été une décision évidente pour vous
spontanée où vous avez dû réfléchir
pourquoi en tout cas vous avez accepté
cette méthode
voilà très
déterminé en tout cas en fait ça s'est
fait effectivement assez rapidement on
s'est retrouvé en fait au mois d'avril
avec des charges qui nous ont été
demandées qui étaient très importantes à
se retrouver confiné je pense que
beaucoup de gens ont vécu on s'est aussi
retrouvée nous dans la cour de
l'immeuble a échangé un peu plus que
d'habitude et du coup on a pu aussi
partager un peu nos difficultés nos
questionnements par rapport à la
situation et du coup suite à ce rappel
de charge très très important qui
arrivait à un moment très opportun on va
dire on a commencé à réfléchir l'une des
locataires a contacté l'association
droit au logement et les voilà en étant
avec eux et en réfléchissant avec eux on
s'est dit qu'on voulait participer à
toute leur campagne de moratoire sur les
loyers et demander justement qui est
cette cette opération de moratoire sur
les loyers qu'ils soient mises en place
comment ont réagi les propriétaires
parce qu'on rappelle que c'est un parc
privé ce ne sont pas voilà ce n'est pas
publique
ce sont donc des propriétaires
d'immeubles qui ne perçoivent pas de
loyer on imagine que c'est alors
certains peut-être ne peuvent pas de
s'apitoyer sur des propriétaires mais ça
peut être difficile aussi pour eux
d'être privé de ses loyers ils étaient
peut-être aussi dans des situations
compliquées avec cette crise du coc vide
oui peut-être
je vous avoue que ça je sais pas ce que
c'est c'est que on a un seul bailleur
surtout l'immeuble on n'a pas plusieurs
bailleurs plusieurs propriétaires
individuels
donc c'est un gros bailleurs qui gère
l'entièreté de lyme
après ce qui s'est passé c'est que nous
on a créé ce comité des locataires pour
justement un peu suivre les
revendications et pouvoir se mettre
ensemble pour suivre toute la
mobilisation et on a envoyé un courrier
à la société de gestion qui avec
laquelle on met en lien pour faire un
petit peu l'état des lieux et demander
justement rendez vous pour pouvoir
évoquer les situations à la fois les
situations de difficultés par rapport au
paiement des loyers mais aussi des
difficultés dans l'entretien des
appartements etc et donc on a reçu une
réponse à peu près une semaine ou dix
jours plus tard ou voilà c'était un peu
un évitement et on nous a répondu
effectivement comme je le disais que on
ne pouvait pas venir nous voir à côté
prochainement on espère qu'on va avoir
le rendez vous très bien aujourd'hui
dans quelle situation
etes-vous aucun revenu pendant le
confinement alors vous - personnellement
effectivement les locataires qui ont
décidé de ne plus payer effectivement
leurs charges on imagine que même
étaient dans des situations difficiles
alors en fait nous on a décidé de faire
une opération commune et solidaire ya
parmi nous des gens qui ne peuvent
absolument pas payer leur loyer qui
n'ont pas eu de revenus depuis le moi de
le début du mois de mars
et puis il ya des gens qui pourraient
éventuellement payer leur loyer mais qui
par solidarité avec les autres ont
décidé de ne pas payer leur loyer pour
l'instant aujourd'hui c'est une grève
des loyers dans le privé
c'est une démarche plutôt inédit qui on
l'a vu dans le reportage soutenu par par
le dal l'organisation tout à fait en
fait droit au logement nous a vraiment
accompagné d'un conseiller et c'est
vraiment avec eux qu'on avance dans
cette aventure je dirais d'ailleurs
j'invite tout le monde à aller signer
leur pétition pour un moratoire sur les
loyers qui est sûr le litre le site
loyer suspendu point org pour participer
aussi à cette campagne
aujourd'hui clairement est ce que vous
vous craignez d'être obligé de
rembourser tous les loyers
rétroactivement que dit la loi sur sur
ce plan alors je suis pas une
spécialiste
l'enseigné on imagine tout l'immeuble
avant de prendre cette décision
oui tout à fait pour l'instant on est
vraiment dans une salle pendant deux
mois en fait on a vraiment une phase qui
est une phase de négociations pendant
laquelle il peut pas y avoir d'action en
justice trop importante
ce qu'ils peuvent mettre le loyer de
côté bien évidemment pour pouvoir le
régler
si jamais on a un rappel à la loi de
payer et puis voilà on est dans cette
période des deux mois qui nous permet
d'essayer d'instaurer un dialogue avec
notre bailleur et deux points d'avancé
sur cette question merci hélène roger
habitants donc de l'immeuble en grève
des loyers de bagnolet d'avoir été avec
nous merci à vous l'institut montaigne
publié un rapport sévère analysant
l'impuissance des institutions de l'état
concernant l'emploi et l'insertion en
seine saint denis 1 l'étude met en
lumière les raisons de l'inefficacité et
rêve
l'échec des pouvoirs publics ces
dernières années alors que les projets
opportunités sont nombreux dans le
département les explications des tailles
de monein à bout dès lors c'est
l'histoire d'un paradoxe qui gangrène la
seine saint denis depuis des années
pourquoi ce département situé aux portes
de paris
stagner dans la pauvreté alors qu'il
bénéficie de nombreux atouts
c'est la question que s'est posée
l'institut montaigne leur enquête détail
plusieurs points et propose même des
solutions en seine saint denis les
initiatives ne manquent pas le
département regroupe 500 bissieux projet
avec le grand paris
le cdg express les infrastructures pour
les jo
le développement du terminal 4 de
l'aéroport charles de gaulle et enfin
elle la réalisation du campus hospitalo
universitaires grand paris nord en tout
près de 20 milliards d'euros
d'investissements publics répartis sur
les 15 prochaines années
sauf que ce dynamisme économique profite
peu aux habitants à près d'un tiers
vivent avec moins de 1000 60 euros par
mois et les jeunes sont particulièrement
touchés par le chômage puisque 28% des
personnes âgées de 18 à 24 ans sont sans
emploi ni formation soit 13 points de
plus que dans les hauts-de-seine par
exemple selon l'institut montaigne et
chaque jour près de 300000 personnes
viennent travailler dans le département
soit 43 % des emplois du territoire
l'explication est bien l'offre d'emploi
de cadres et professions intellectuelles
supérieures est plus élevé que les
besoins de la main d'oeuvre locale
ainsi les employeurs sont donc
contraints de recourir à des personnes
extérieures tandis que les résidents
sont donc poussé à sortir du département
pour travailler l'enquêté révèle
également l'absence d'une véritable
stratégie dans le domaine de l'éducation
les enseignants débutants sont affectés
dans des établissements difficiles et
une importante partie de reste moins de
deux ans au même poste à titre d'exemple
49 % des professeurs à l'école ne sont
pas remplacés pour une moyenne de 22 % à
l'échelle nationale des absences qui
peuvent avoir de lourdes conséquences
sur l'éducation des élèves
il ya aussi le cas des étudiants et
des quartiers populaires qu'on laisse
tomber dès qu'ils arrivent à
l'université il ne bénéficie d'aucun
suivi ni de réseau et finissent par
s'inscrire au chômage
l' enquête suggère que les opérateurs
mandatée pour accompagner les élèves
jusqu'à l'emploi devrait bénéficier de
financements plus importants
autre élément significatif dans le
budget du département
les fonds qui devrait être dédiée à
l'insertion sont absorbés par le coût du
versement et prestations jrs à ce
montant s'élève à 505 millions d'euros
pour seulement 317 millions d'euros de
recettes
dès lors il est impossible de créer une
dynamique à la hauteur des enjeux
les projets sont là le potentiel aussi
mais le département a besoin d'être
repensé et aborder de manière différente
et avec la crise sanitaire liée aux
convives 19 la situation pourrait se
dégrader
l'enquète l'a démontré il faut donc plus
de moyens et une répartition des chances
égalitaire pour permettre au département
d'exploiter ses capacités alors pourquoi
la seine saint denis est situé aux
portes de paris reste enlisée dans la
pauvreté alors qu'elle a tous les atouts
a priori pour décoller le département et
il stigmatise et c'est l'objet de notre
face à face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct avec eux mêmes aides kaki
sociologue président de l'association
mémorielle et orange à ses côtés
alexandre vecchio journalistes le figaro
qui a grandit d'ailleurs il faut le
préciser en seine saint denis c'est donc
un département qu'il connaît bien
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france là on
vient de le voir en la seine saint denis
qui est de nombreux atouts une
population jeune du dynamisme la
proximité avec la capitale des projets
comme le cdg express ou encore les géo à
venir et pourtant ça reste le
département le plus pauvre de france
comment vous vous l'expliquer on
commence par vous même être kaki écoutez
d'abord le mot lui même le mot
stigmatisation jeu moi je préfère le mot
disqualification parce que le mot
stigmatisation rappelle un moteur
important qui s'appelle evry hoffman qui
a travaillé sur les handicapés sur asile
notamment et sur comment la
stigmatisation à arras et pour les
handicapés donc un ce mot la
disqualification médiatique et politique
est plus approprié pour ce département
la deuxième chose qui est très
importante c'est quand même temps c'est
un département attractif où il ya une
cour doit tease extrêmement importantes
notamment à travers le foncier il suffit
de voir bagnolet montreuil enfin toutes
ces villes qui sont autour et autres
ailleurs qui sont très convoités par la
bourgeoisie du centre ville de paris et
donc qui veut s'installer elle et qui
fait augmenter d'ailleurs un foncier
très important donc voyez il ya un
paradoxe entre à la fois le mot
disqualification stigmatisation comme
vous l'avez dit c'est la question qu'a
justement est-ce que c'est un
département qui est stigmatisé faux
frais d'une
voilà justement des raisons pour
lesquelles elle s'enlise ray dans la
pauvreté alors qu'elle a peint des tons
c'était une question c'est ça alors
justement deuxième chose c'est un
département jaune parce que le numéro 93
a été créé en 1968 et savez vous que
d'où vient ce chiffre et ce chiffre 93
eh bien il nous vient de constantine une
ville en algérie c'était le numéro de la
ville de constantine en algérie dans
l'histoire coloniale voyez-vous et donc
ça a été donnée par le général de gaulle
à l'époque oui pour créer la
seine-saint-denis justement pour créer
ce département qui est qui était un
bastion ouvrier très important dirigée
par le parti communiste il faut le
rappeler
pendant très très longtemps et en même
temps c'est une histoire très longue
début du 19e siècle c'est
l'industrialisation c'est les usines
c'est eux
je dirais une économie très important
qui s'installe et c'est un prolétariat à
la base donc un lieu de travail de
ressources de travailleurs portant où
les gens ont grandi en travail et en
construit ce qui vous voulez ce
département qui encore une fois très
convoité par la bourgeoisie
on va donner la parole à alexandre ii
vecchio excentrique ya plusieurs idées
qui ont été véhiculées par mohammad taqi
disqualification médiatique j'ai retenu
et puis effectivement une une pression
immobilière la bourgeoisie comme l'a
qualifié en tout cas au m'hamed kaki qui
souhaitent s'y installer c'était
intéressant cette petite partie
historique qui rappelle que c'était
effectivement un département dans lequel
il y avait les usines
l'industrialisation dont beaucoup de
travail quelle est la réaction à toutes
ces idées on va essayer de les
structurer un peu alexandre ii vecchio
moi j'ai pas forcément de de réactions
négatives à ces idées là sur la
disqualification je suis un peu plus
sceptique c'est un goût à un département
qui peut avoir mauvaise réputation mais
je pense parce qu'il a des aussi les
problèmes réels d'insécurité
d'intégration etc
je pense que la pauvreté elle est lié à
plusieurs choses on a parlé de la genèse
département c'est aussi un département
jeunes parce qu'ils comptent le plus de
jeunes en froisser de toute façon la
jeunesse de manière logique et peut-être
plus pour que les gens qui sont
installés dans la vie à l'âge adulte
c'est un département qui a été une
tradition ouvrière
aujourd'hui ça reste un département
ouvriers mais sur fond de désert
puisqu'il ya 10 à soin aussi sur fond
d'immigration
donc effectivement c'est une population
pauvre qui vient vous pour retrouver du
travail
au moment justement où la france subit
une désindustrialisation massive à
partir des années 70 80 et encore plus
aujourd'hui donc tout ceci explique la
pauvreté après moi je crois que les
immigrés qui viennent l'itie malgré tous
c'est un c'est un progrès par rapport à
leur pays à leur pays d'origine donc il
faut relativiser également la pauvreté
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup d'eux on peut
donner aussi une meilleure image du 93
on l'a vu pendant la crise du coup
rotavirus il y avait beaucoup d'autres
soignants beaucoup de travailleurs qui
ont été les fameuses première ligne qui
ont été au fond après il ya
effectivement ce que je disais en
préambule ces difficultés d'intégration
ces tensions sécuritaires ces tensions
culturelles qui sont pas aussi seulement
liés
mon avis à la question sociale ça en
fait partie des questions d'urbanisme
qui commence à être réglé avec l'édile a
rappelé en banlieue mais il ya aussi
effectivement des questions de
délinquance de communautarisme de
violence voilà qu'ils soient une réalité
qu'il faut pas nier et je suis pas sûr
qu'elle soit uniquement lié à la
pauvreté on l'a vu malgré tout un grand
effort a été fait dans la rénovation
urbaine il ya un grand est forfait pour
les politiques sociales mais il ya
toujours ces tensions qui sont liées à
mon avis - essentiellement un problème
noté lancement elle même est acquis
intégration tension sécuritaire
délinquance communautarisme ce sont des
bons qu'il vous faut bondir où vous êtes
d'accord avec le diagnostic d'alexandre
ii vecchio qui ferait donc partie des
choses qui plombe introduit un petit peu
ce département écoutez moi je n'ai pas
parlé ouvre tes je vais parler de
ressources
je pense que dans ce département il ya
des richesses a été dit notamment autres
à travers la jeunesse il y à des
énergies importantes qui sont comme
l'ont été dans le passé leurs parents
les gens qui ont construit et ce
département n'est pas seulement le
produit de l'immigration c'est le
produit la classe ouvrière française
il faut le rappeler et l'immigration
fait partie de cette classe ouvrière
donc ça c'est très très importante
après il y a eu il faut parler surtout
des politiques publiques c'est à dire
comment on en est venu là difficulté
pourquoi ce département plus de
difficultés que d'autres départements il
faut le rappeler on l'a dit tout à
l'heure que dès le départ l'est parisien
et notamment le 93 a été c'est le lieu
des usines c'est le lieu du travail et
c'est le lieu justement où les par
exemple à côté dans l'ouest parisien
c'était des riches qui se sont installés
dans la verdure dans les lieux sympas
comme on dit
et paradoxalement aujourd'hui où est-ce
qu'on en est la vraie discussion c'est
que aujourd'hui c'est la puissance
publique que font les services locaux
font que fait la puissance publique et
l'état par rapport à un certain nombre
de problématiques que rencontrent la
jeunesse un l'emploi notamment et c'est
à travers cette désindustrialisation et
on voit qu'il n'ya pas de corrélation se
voyait que par exemple dans une ville
comme saint denis
on s'installe des entreprises de pointe
de technologie importante ou notamment
due à la question de langage de la
jeunesse pose problème
est ce que on va donner on va en
profiter par des témoins à la jeunesse
et babel kaki pardonnez mon un petit
rôle de lien avec vous et comme bons
comme la réponse est assez lent on va en
profiter de ce prêtre de liaison pour
donner la parole à alexandre ii vecchio
effectivement alexandre de vecchi on dit
souvent voilà ces jeunes qui ne sont pas
toujours employé alors mannequin qui n'a
pas prononcé du tout le mode
discrimination mais enfin
son coach parle sous son contrôle c'est
peut-être qu'il allait certainement dire
et or voilà que c'est compliqué pour ces
jeunes de ce département les politiques
publiques qu'est ce que vous répondez ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec ces propos
autant sur le diagnostic on pouvait être
en accord tout à l'heure beaucoup de
points pour se rejoindre au taux majoré
ou je trouve que la puissance publique
passée beaucoup malgré tout pour pour ce
département la gdi de multiples plans
pour euros pour les banlieues à chacun
des d'ailleurs nouveau mandat dernière
dans notre interview du ghana et à une
politique de la ville qui est mise en
place mais on s'aperçoit alors c'est
bien la rénovation urbaine moi je suis
pas content parce que je pense qu'il
faut à améliorer les conditions de vie
effectivement des gens lui même dans un
meilleur cadre on vit mieux que ce sens
et sans doute que ça facilite beaucoup
de choses mais ça ne résout pas tout
d'ailleurs quand on parle à ses
habitants ont dit on leur a construit
parfois des maisons de pauvres des
immeubles meilleur et on voit bien que
les problèmes d'insécurité de tensions
continues tu vois je ne crois pas que
c'est lui à une discrimination je crois
que l'état a été gêné house a même tenté
de mettre en place parfois des
politiques de discrimination positive
je crois que c'est lié à un problème
d'intégration tâter nation culturelle
c'est à dire la voir les codes culturels
pour demande d'avoir dans le pays et
aussi en entreprise les codes des codes
sociaux avec ces deux là dessus qu'il
faut faire un effort et que justement de
le discours victimaire est parfois père
messieurs et contre productif puisque
quand on répète à une population qu'elle
est victime victime de discrimination
avait fini par le croire et avoir du
ressentiment donc je crois qu'on doit
aussi insister sur ce qui a été fait
pour ce département pour ces populations
là et miser sur leur intelligence leur
capacité d'ascension sociale et
d'intégration est pas tout
les considérer comme des victimes
discriminer mois m k qui y est le mot de
la fin et surtout la réponse parce que
soit raisonnement c'est vrai souvent en
opposition avec un raisonnement de
victimisation est ce que
c'est un début aussi de solutions
peut-être regarder ce qui a été fait la
valorisation de ce qui est fait et puis
peut-être arrêter de regarder ces
personnes comme des victimes tout
simplement écouter du n'y a pas de
victimation il y à des combats que
mènent des associations que mène des
jeunes en aucun cas vous verrez
responsables associatifs a parlé de
misérabilisme ou de victimisation
au contraire les gens sont dans le
combat tous les jours ou un conte cas
pour la dignité pour la vie est
effectivement l'enjeu libéraux 1 c'est
la question de l'emploi ce à seulement
the le saupoudrage que peut mettre en
place les pouvoirs publics ici ou là
c'est la question de l'emploi la
question de l'emploi des jeunes la
question de nos politiques sur le long
terme
or de ce point de vue là qu'il ya une
panne et une panne générale et donc
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut donner de
l'espoir à l'ensemble de cette jeunesse
et de relance en 2d ces familles qui
vivent là qui ne demande qu'à une chose
qui demande à travailler d'ailleurs un
je ne le ferais je vous rappellerai que
beaucoup de gens de ces travailleurs
diana à paris et font le travail dans
les bureaux avec les plus grande
pénibilité donc la question du travail
la question de la jeunesse elle et elle
et elle est au centre de cette affaire
et en aucun cas les gens un pleur sur
leur sort ou son se victimise comédie
parce que ça encore une fois c'est un
processus de disqualification
quand on dit victimisation c'est là que
l'on on disqualifie des gens moi je ne
pense pas du tout qu'il ya ça je pense
que ce que je vois autour de moi ou
alors on vit pas dans les mêmes endroits
il y a des gens qui un qui combat pour
une dignité pour leur histoire et vous
voyez on parlait de deux d'école on est
on est on est d'accord moi je parlais
des discours médiatique qu'on entend
qu'on entend parfois et qui sont parfois
caricaturaux et ont parlé d'association
il ya des associations qui font du bon
travail il ya des associations qui
malheur des gens une forme de rente et
donc moi je me méfie beaucoup de ceux
qui justement propagent ces discours
ensuite je vous rejoins en vous dites
qu'il ya un problème d'emploi qui a un
problème de désindustrialisation qui est
un problème pour la jeunesse trouver du
travail mais j'ai envie de dire que ça
touche pas seulement la jeunesse de
seine saint denis en réalité vous allez
en creuse et en lozère la puissance
publique peut être beaucoup moins
investi que dans certaines et un
quartier de 7,5 me c'est pour
relativiser mais c'est pour dire qu'il
n'ya pas de discrimination qu'au
contraire les pouvoirs publics ont pris
la mesure de toutes ces choses les
problèmes de délinquance et de tensions
communautaires qui n'ont rien à voir
et là on était là avec la pauvreté merci
à tous les deux désole son arrive
vraiment la fin de ce débat - avec quel
qui désole on vous a entendu beaucoup
tous les deux d'avoir été avec nous en
direct
voilà exactement on continuera ce débat
merci à tous les deux en tout cas le
bilan du coronavirus non l'hexagone à
présent un petit mot 16 jours a pas de
déconfinement progressive c'est
important la baisse du nombre de
personnes en réanimation se poursuit
avec 54 de moins selon elle les chiffres
de la direction générale de la santé oms
contre 66 nouveaux décès ce qui fait un
total de 28 596 personnes décédées
depuis le début de l'épidémie l'épidémie
des chiffres encourageants mais
évidemment la prudence reste de mise
avant les annonces du premier ministre
demain qui devrait préciser quelles sont
les régions qui passe en verre et celle
qui reste en rouge
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous partirons libye la russie dément y
avoir envoyé des avions de chasse pour
soutenir des mercenaires au sol
combattant aux côtés du maréchal haftar
comme l'accusent des états unis puis
nous parlerons des théories du complot
qui se propage avec le virus une étude
britannique s'est penché sur les
conséquences que pourraient avoir ces
fausses informations
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on a une idée de
l'augmentation ou pas des signes ici
d'aujourd'hui en france les cours et les
violences existait avant leur
confinement
et pendant ce confinement c'est vrai
qu'il ya sept ce cadre lecture les taux
de féminicide a plus que je suis pas
doublé mais bien monté forcément on n'a
pas encore tous les chiffres officiels
c'est très difficile gros n'est jamais
n'est jamais loin finalement c'est le
confinement dans le confinement
cela veut dire qu'il y en a huit clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément donc les femmes victimes de
violences de nombreux endroits à 3
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre en
direct sur rt france 21h30 heure de
paris la libye au coeur des tensions
entre washington et moscou le commandant
en chef des forces armées américaines en
afrique a accusé hier à la russie
d'avoir déployé des avions de chasse
pour soutenir des mercenaires présent au
sol ces derniers combattants aux côtés
du maréchal khalifa haftar opposants au
gouvernement de tripoli
reconnu par l'onu ces accusations ont
été démenties par moscou qui les
qualifie de fausses nouvelles a vanté
par washington mais en fait le point
avec notre correspondante onecare ou à
moscou
tout commence avec la publication d'un
communiqué du commandement des états
unis pour l'afrique avec prudence le
document estime que des avions de combat
russes ont été récemment déployé en
libye et fournirait un soutien aérien à
des sociétés militaires privées
sur le terrain les avions en question
serait arrivé depuis la russie bien la
base aérienne russe située en syrie où
il aurait été repeint pour masquer leur
origine les responsables militaires qui
ont ensuite commenté ce communiqué de
presse ne se sont pas embarrassés de
l'emploi du conditionnel ainsi un porte
parole du pentagone affirme sans ambages
que les russes ont envoyé 14 avions
militaires en libye une accusation que
réfute moscou le vice président de la
commission à la défense de la douma
rodrik race of a répondu que cette
information je cite ne correspondait pas
à la réalité il au passage rappelé la
position de la russie sur ce dossier
comme quoi moscou appelle à la fin des
effusions de sang en libye et exhorte
toutes les parties au conflit à ne pas
avoir recours aux armes mais plutôt à
s'asseoir à la table des négociations et
pour en parler nous sommes avec céline
je rédige géopolitologue bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous
direct sur rt france les accusations de
washington
le démenti de la russie l'onu qui
confirme elle une présence russe
les avions de chasse donc que peut-on
dire et comment peut-on y voir plus
clair
lille bonsoir en fait je crois que on
est dans une situation quasi aux
politiques assez intéressant par rapport
à ce qui se passe en libye
on est en train de faire un peu le jeu
de la patate chaude entre les états unis
et la russie
toutefois pour des informations qu'on
reçoit et quand on essaie de 2,2 d'avoir
en ce moment des confirme tout ce qu'il
ya quand même une aide russe a par
rapport au maréchal haftar sur place en
contrepartie pour essayer de créer un
équilibre entre le soutien sur ta celui
de sa rage qui est représente le gel a
sur place et donc il ya de fortes
chances qu'il ya eu vraiment des appuis
sachant que la russie a toujours soutenu
la position de un peu diplomatique
si je peux appeler ça comme ça et pour
dire que y'a quand même un gouvernement
qui est assez officielle dans celui de
la salle âge mais les informations que
qui sont présentes je ne crois pas que
les états unis a eu cette information ou
à essayer de démasquer cette information
sans pour autant avoir des des
informations assez sûre toutefois la
situation qu'on voit aujourd'hui libye
c'est une situation qui est assez
complexe mais qui rentre dans une phase
qui est très très compliqué surtout que
avec l'appui de guy maréchal haftar qui
avait perdu un peu la main il ya
quelques semaines et qui essaient de
revenir un peu sur en fait qui revient
lui revient un peu sur la scène avec
beaucoup plus de force on sait qu'il est
pour les non seulement d'une façon
directe par les pays qu'on connaît un
certain pays du golfe dans les émirats
arabes et aussi l'egypte sans le sait
clairement mais aussi et a quand même un
soutien c'est passible de la france qui
la diplomatie française qui je dirais
pas qu'il joue
double jeu mais on sait très bien que la
france elle a toujours soutenu
diplomatiquement le maréchal afta
sachant qu elle tout en reconnaissant un
peu la savage que comme président
officiel de la libye
toutefois on assiste aussi à une
ségrégation socio spatiales aujourd'hui
on les beats avec le retour avec on
retrouve avec une à ce pays la libye
avec trois pays en l'occurrence des pays
où on retrouve le gouvernement en ce
moment appelé parlement de tomates avec
regret la salle on a aussi savage qui
est le président officiel est de dix
gouvernements ont là aussi l'espace sud
du maréchal haftar donc toutes ces
situations là mais la libye dans une
deuxième phase qui est très très
compliqué ce qui ne plaît pas beaucoup
aux occidentaux est ce qu'ils ont mais
les occidentaux surtout a signifié ou
est-ce internet d'une façon plus directe
parce qu'il ya quand même beaucoup
d'intérêt dans le pays on n'a pas vu ça
par exemple pour un pays comme le yémen
parce qu'il représente pas beaucoup de
pays beaucoup d'intérêt pour l'europe
mais contrairement à la libye et qu'il
ya plusieurs volets le volet sécuritaire
le volet économique
si un volet d'une ouverture sur les pays
de l'afrique et surtout nord africains
dans toutefois on est remonté
pardonnez-moi le maréchal f tard
justement est ce qu'il est dans une
position affaiblie aujourd'hui
enfin moi je ne crois pas en fait tout
le monde essaie de faire à cette
hypothèse que le maréchal haftar il est
affaibli la paire du terral a perdu
tripoli mais moi j'ai l'impression en
fait mais j'en suis persuadé qu'il est
en train de se repositionner faut pas
oublier que le maréchal haftar c'est pas
c'est un c'est un militaire avait ré
c'est quelqu'un qui connaît très très
bien la fille qui se fait aider par là
tout le monde parle de ma mère l'est la
société un peu secrète de la russie mais
on parle aussi des gens vite qu'ils sont
les
les une armée très dur soudanaises mais
il ya beaucoup de subsahariens dans les
légendes du tchad et on sait très bien
que le maréchal after était en mission
la compétition en afrique dans la ilaha
illa ces réseaux donc sur le terrain
au jour d'aujourd'hui on peut dire que
la star c'est le gagnant aujourd'hui sur
le terrain ce qui déplaît beaucoup à
savage est assez aux alliés de savage
dans la turquie dont l occident essayer
de faire un équilibre entre les deux
forces tout en maintenant ou en
soutenant un star parce qu'ils sachent
très très bien c'est l'homme du terrain
aujourd'hui c'est un c'est un militaire
qui connaît très bien la région il a une
popularité quoiqu'en l'ignorent au conte
au qu'on essaie de des deniers mais ça
reste l'homme du terrain sur lequel
l'europe en général et la france en
particulier anisé et continuera de miser
dessus
un merci à céline résident avoir été
avec nous avoir apporté votre point de
vue est votre analyse le 1er juin c'est
la date à laquelle moscou devrait
assouplir ces mesures de confinement
liées à la crise du coronavirus le maire
de la ville envisage la réouverture des
commerces avec des conditions
spécifiques le retour des sorties et des
promenades pour les moscovites on le
rappelle moscou est l'un des principaux
foyers du pays avec plus de 170
milliards enregistrés écouter le maire
de la ville qui présente les détails de
son assouplissement à partir du 1er juin
nous proposons d'ouvrir non seulement
les commerces alimentaires mais aussi
tous les magasins non alimentaires
deuxièmement nous proposons d'ouvrir une
partie des services à la personne qui
n'impose pas de contacts de longue durée
avec la personne ce sont les
blanchisseries les ateliers de
réparation et cetera
ces services sont aussi important et le
plus important pour les citoyens qui
sont restés chez eux pendant ces
derniers mois
c'est de pouvoir sortir se promener dans
la rue dans un square dans un parc
nous proposons de faire cela sous la
forme d'essai et d'établir un calendrier
selon lequel les gens de telle ou telle
immeubles peuvent sortir de faire le
calendrier le plus simple et le plus
accessible pour qu'il n'y ait pas
beaucoup de monde en même temps dehors
et de vivre comme ça une ou deux
semaines pour voir comment la situation
va évoluer les théories du complot ont
fait le tour du monde depuis
l'apparition de l'épidémie de
coronavirus tantôt on accuse les juifs
tantôt on accuse les musulmans une étude
britannique publiée par une équipe de
chercheurs de l'université d'oxford
publie des chiffres pour le moins
inquiétant plus de 20 % des anglais
pensent que le coc vie 19 est un complot
préparé par les musulmans et un anglais
sur cinq pense que ce sont plutôt les
juifs qu'ils ont créée dans le but de
s'enrichir pendant la crise économique
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis leicester au royaume uni avec
alister jones professeur politiques
associés de politique pardon à
l'université de montfort de leicester
bonsoir c'est notre rubrique donc vu de
l'extérieur tous les bancs
[Musique]
et voilà bonsoir mr jones merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france ce
soir les chiffres qu'on vient de voir
sont quand même assez inquiétant dont
viennent selon vous ces théories du
complot ils viennent de partout
une des choses les plus intéressantes
c'est la circulation dans les réseaux
sociaux toutes les histoires sont portés
ils peuvent être présentées comme étant
du pur fait et lorsqu'on voit les
détails de cette recherche
ils ont étudié ou les personnes
obtenaient leur information ce qui est
intéressant c'est le manque de confiance
envers le gouvernement et l'information
qui propage et envers les autres sources
traditionnelles de formation c'est
l'information véhiculée par antonin 37
eu des défaites minus des médias qui
essayent de tromper les gens de cacher
la vérité
et oui lorsque ce genre d'histoires
commencent à circuler alors elles
prennent de l'ampleur
les chercheurs de cette étude ont
découvert que 59% que d'après ces
personnes 59 % des gens pensent que les
autorités essayent de tromper les gens
mais le sauvetage pourrait être encore
plus important c'est le niveau de
méfiance envers le gouvernement
voici donc pourquoi ces versions
alternatives de la réalité apparaissent
alors on peut être anti système on peut
ne pas faire confiance aux autorités au
gouvernement mais là les chiffres qu'on
vient de voir pardonnez moi mais ça
confinent au racisme à l'antisémitisme
les gens sont crédules à ce point là où
il ya un fond tout simplement de racisme
et d'antisémitisme
je pense que c'est un mélange des deux
lorsqu'on regarde les personnes
impliquées et les personnes qui sont le
plus susceptibles de croire à ces
théories du complot effectivement ce
sont des extrémistes de la gauche ou de
la droite et dans ces zones
effectivement on trouve plus de racisme
et d'antisémitisme
au centre il ya des personnes qui ont
tendance à être plus stable donc
effectivement il ya du racisme et
l'antisémisme si on étudie les origines
haution sur la question des origines 20
tu coronavirus 20% des personnes
interrogées pensaient qu'il s'agissait
d'un complot et chinois arabe ou juif
donc ces histoires sont propagées dans
les réseaux sociaux qui est en fait une
chambre d'écho une chambre de résonance
donc il écoute les personnes qu'ils
suscitent de croire et répète ces
informations à des personnes qui sont
également susceptibles de le croire et
donc ces informations tournent dans des
réseaux très serré effectivement là-bas
on trouve du racisme et l'antisémitisme
à leicester jones justement c'est
intéressant de savoir qui propagent ces
nouvelles est ce que ce sont justement
des gens qui cherchent à manipuler
l'opinion ou se sont simplement de de
simples citoyens
voilà qui font des fêtes news justement
vous l'avez une très bien expliquée par
avec des opinions racistes antisémites
et qui ont tout simplement vite propagé
de laine sur les réseaux sociaux
le source
la source puis se trouver n'importe où
si vous allez sur facebook ou twitter et
que quelqu'un peut bien message disant à
telle personne est morte le message et
retweeter ou et partager la personne
n'aurait pu mourir il ya cinq ou dix ans
mais l'histoire
elle présentait comme étant une nouvelle
donc certaines personnes propagent ces
histoires en pensons
de bonne foi quelle qu'elles sont vraies
cela peut être dû au manque d'éducation
de son site de conscience sociale
montante avoir un degré d'innocence ou
en tout cas de naïveté parmi certaines
de ces personnes mais il ya également
des éléments marginaux qui propagent
volontairement ces histoires et eux seul
et fut profondément des réseaux
traditionnels de ce que donald trump
qualifie de fake muse donc quelles que
soient les informations véhiculées par
les réseaux des informations
traditionnelles ils pensent le contraire
donc quelles que soient les profs qu'on
leur présente ces personnes vont refuser
d'être persuadé ils vont continuer à
faire véhiculer ce qu'ils pensent être
des faits et donc ces marginaux sont de
plus en plus mainstream
de nombreuses rumeurs ont été présentés
lundi dans les médias que le coronavirus
était liée à l'installation des réseaux
5g et d'emma 5g ont été détruits parce
que des gens pensaient que c'était
l'origine du coronavirus donc il y a des
naïfs mais il ya également des marchés
nous et on le comprend bien merci à
lyster jones professeur associé de
politique à l'université de montfort de
leicester d'avoir à essayer et d en tout
cas à comprendre ces théories de complot
le 25 mai les deux ong global health
avocat est très complète observatory ont
publié
résultat de deux rapports des enquêtes
elle dévoile comment des milliards
d'euros destiné à la recherche
européenne bénéficie en réalité à dreux
grands groupes industriels au détriment
du bien commun
estelle fages au nom de l'innovation
voici comment s'intitule les deux
rapports d'enquêté publié par deux ong
action santé mondiale qui lutte contre
les inégalités en matière de santé et
corporate europe observatory qui est
spécialisée dans le lobbying
dans leur rapport les deux organisations
accusent l'industrie pharmaceutique
d'avoir pris le contrôle des fonds de
recherche au détriment de l'intérêt
général
les rapports décrivent des partenariats
qui octroie des privilèges et des
avantages au secteur privé tout en
imposant des devoirs et des obligations
au secteur public avec des conséquences
inquiétantes pour l'intérêt général sur
un large éventail de sujets de la
négligence vis-à-vis de la préparation
aux épidémies à l'aggravation de la
déforestation et du changement
climatique pour en venir à cette
conclusion les deux organisations se
sont intéressés aux partenariats public
privé conclu entre la direction générale
recherche et innovation de la commission
européenne et des lobbies industriels
depuis 2000 14,7 partenariat public
privé ont ainsi été conclu
les ong en ont déplu chez 2 l'initiative
pour les médicaments innovants imi et
celle pour les bio beeld industry
prenons les amis par exemple
c'est donc un partenariat public privé
créée en 2008 entre la commission
européenne et la fédération européenne
des industries et associations
pharmaceutiques le fp ya autrement dit
le principal lobby européen du secteur
voici l'objectif de ce partenariat tel
qu'il est présenté sur son site internet
nous espérons améliorer la santé en
accélérant le développement de
médicaments innovants et l'accès des
patients à ses produits en particulier
dans les régions où les besoins médicaux
sociaux ne sont pas couverts
le budget de ce partenariat s'élèvent à
plus de 5 milliards d'euros depuis sa
création
sur cette somme 2
milliards d'euros proviennent de
financement public selon les ong ces
fonds publics ont été utilisés pour
servir des intérêts commerciaux et non
pour réaliser les objectifs premiers du
partenariat lie amis n'investit pas dans
des domaines où un financement public
est nécessaire de toute urgence telle
que la préparation à long terme aux
épidémies le vih sida les maladies liées
à la pauvreté et les maladies tropicales
négligées
mais il investit lourdement dans des
domaines très profitable dans lesquels
l'industrie pharmaceutique investit déjà
des ressources considérables liés mines
ne contribue pas à rendre les
médicaments plus accessible mais plutôt
à enraciner un système qui fait monter
en flèche les prix des médicaments et de
fait grève les budgets nationaux de
santé de son côté l'initiative pour les
médicaments innovants a réagi notamment
sur son site internet
elle reproche aux ong de faire des
généralités à partir de quelques défis
isolé nous sommes déçus que les auteurs
aient manqué l'occasion de contribuer à
un débat constructif sur l'ia me et les
partenariats public privé de santé
nous regrettons que le rapport cible des
défis isolé ho kelly amy a été confronté
et on déduit des généralités afin de
discréditer l'intégrité du programme
quant au second partenariat public-privé
analysés par les deux ong
le constat est sensiblement le même les
organisations ont accompagné leurs
rapports de recommandations elle
conseille notamment à la commission
européenne de mettre en oeuvre je cite
de sérieuses réformes de transparence et
d'inclusion afin que ces programmes
deviennent plus pertinent pour l'intérêt
public aux états unis à quelques mois de
la présidentielle donald trump et son
adversaire jo baydan reprennent
doucement leur campagne électorale est
quelque peu chamboulé évidemment par la
crise sanitaire qui a endeuillé le pays
clément hospital la campagne
présidentielle a repris à couteaux tirés
aux états unis lors de sa première
sortie depuis plus de deux mois lundi
joe biden est apparue avec un masque
noir sur le visage une apparition
marquant une nette différence avec son
rival donald trump qui refuse de porter
cet accessoire lors de grands
rassemblements
ce dernier a d'ailleurs raillé le
candidat démocrate en retweetant un
poste d'un journaliste de fox news
même s'il dit ne pas l'avoir critique
ceci pourrait expliquer pourquoi trump
n'aime pas porter un masque en public
voici by donne aujourd'hui byden peut
porter un masque mais il était debout
dehors avec sa femme dans des conditions
parfaites une météo parfaite il ne porte
pas de masque à l'intérieur donc je me
suis dit que c'était quelque chose de
très inhabituel qui l'emportera je ne le
critique est pas du tout et pour joe
biden le port du masque est au contraire
un signe de leadership dirigé en donnant
l'exemple comme le déclare le candidat
démocrate sur le plateau de cnn
de quoi tacler son rival donald trump
tout en plaçant le port du masque et la
gestion de la crise sanitaire au coeur
de sa campagne
c'est un crétin un crétin absolue de
parler de cette façon tous les toubibs
du monde disent qu'il faut porter un
masque
lorsqu'on est dans un lieu public le
coronavirus et depuis qu'il est apparu
un argument de campagne et pourrait être
un des enjeux majeurs de l'élection
présidentielle car tandis que les
électeurs vont devoir limiter leurs
sorties en meeting le duel entre donald
trump et joe biden se déplace sur
snapshot
l'objectif est de séduire les 18-39 ans
qui représentent 35 % de l'électorat
américain des électeurs pour qu'ils les
réseaux sociaux traditionnels comme
facebook ou twitter paraissent désuet
une course dans laquelle donald trump
possède une bonne longueur d'avancé son
nombre d'abonnés sur snapshot a triplé
durant les huit derniers mois jusqu'à
atteindre 1,5 million d'utilisateurs
l'équipe du candidat démocrate elle
refuse de communiquer les chiffres mais
affirme avoir mis les bouchées doubles
sur le numérique
depuis qu'a commencé la pandémie c'est
la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain ya zem ce sera
demain à 20 heures en attendant point
complet sur l'actualité sous la forme
d'un journal
fx ce sera dans huit minutes a tout de
suite
[Musique]
m
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on fait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de
soins quels sont les facteurs qui vont
nous permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et la faune 42 résilience
la catastrophe économique dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
cata strophe là il ya un tournant et on
recevait à vivre mais dans une autre
direction
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines la moitié de la
planète
jamais on a fait ça jamais là d'une
décision invraisemblable pour vous ça
dépend telles valeurs on attribuait la
mort la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas c'est un débat n'aura
un débat éthique
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici qu'on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques et sur ces sujets sensibles
je vais vous partagez mon intronisation
dans la crise du coc vite 19
c'est toute une chaîne décisionnelle
médicales administratives et politiques
et responsables du fiasco
alors que l' oms recommandait le port du
masque par les populations la parole
publique a longtemps menti sur sa
nécessité pour ne pas avouer la triste
absence du stock regroupe la décision de
confinement s'imposait compte-tenu du
manque de matériel permettant d'autres
solutions mais en freinant l'hécatombe
on pénalise l'économie l'état ne pourra
plus être l'état providence que nous
avons que khurram aura été cimetière de
certaines espérances en pensant que
progrès faisait de nous des hommes dieu
et que les technocrates avec les du
monde demain des conséquences de la
crise oblige à repenser nos modèles la
découverte du télétravail l'intérêt de
consommer des produits locaux le besoin
de solidarité vont faire évoluer une
population qui a découvert qu'elle était
mortel
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
c'est la première fois que tous les pays
de la planète décide finalement de
sacrifier leurs économies pour sauver
des vies humaines
bien sûr c'est sauver des vies mais
c'est aussi conservé l'appareil
productif et permettent que ceux qui
sont dans les secteurs essentiels ceux
qui sont essentiels à l'économie du pays
puissent continuer aussi à travailler
dans le même temps diriez vous que
l'économie française est dans une
situation catastrophique
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que toutes les
planètes sont pas encore alignée pour
qu'on puisse absolument se dire qu'on va
réussir à surmonter de la meilleure
manière possible cette crise j'imagine
que l'initiative franco allemande
s'inscrit dans bug dans votre logique
les 500 milliards c'est une enveloppe
mais il ya un peu une enveloppe en
termes de communication pour l'instant
un engagement oui mais ça veut pas dire
que rabat contrepartie croire que cette
crise du coc vie dorée est passé les
handicaps que nous portions france veut
croire que pas pouvoir repartir à zéro
sans régler les problèmes d'hier et
c'est une erreur
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'attends
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je suis puni
par renoncer aux soins vous avez proposé
deux posters en falck salle que ça veut
dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
construire les fiches avec les acteurs
associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
on est dans une espèce de déni collectif
on ne veut pas croire ce qu'on sait et
scientifique par quand même de la
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre
sixième extinction et la vie sur terre
y'a d'autres experts qui contestent nos
résidents de six personnes non non c'est
pas vrai il ya des climato sinon ce
n'est pas rien à part il ya des gens qui
ne sont pas des chercheurs qui parlent
que la presse met en avant parce que il
faut que du débat le gars plus de débats
aujourd'hui ya plus aucun débat ce
changement climatique et on va faire un
vrai par une catastrophe ou 20 vers une
vraie catastrophe et on est incapable
d'en prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas de pessimiste tout
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense qu'on est comme une guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons vu et l'ennemi y'en a
pas d'ennemis l'ennemi c'est nous
[Musique]
l'hydro xi chloroquine est désormais
interdite en france pour traiter le coït
19 décret et l'autorisant a été abrogée
aujourd'hui par le gouvernement
une décision qui fait suite à l'avis
défavorable du haut conseil de la santé
publique saisie par le ministre de la
santé le professeur à autrui précise qui
continuera à traiter ses patients mais
qu'est les traitements les plus adaptés
à l'instar de plusieurs pays étrangers
qui l'utilisent déjà
la commission européenne propose un
fonds de 750 milliards pour relancer
l'économie des 27 est prouvé par
l'épidémie sa présidente ursula von der
leyen tape du poing sur la table et
appelle les européens à mettre leurs
préjugés de côté à soutenir le projet
tout comme le fait la france hong kong
secouée par des heurts entre forces de
l'ordre et manifestants un mouvement de
rue qui s'opposent à un projet de loi
qui interdit l'outragé l'hymne national
chinois
une nouvelle loi sur la sécurité à hong
kong pourrait voir le jour demain paris
apic un pardon le parlement chinois doit
approuver cette nouvelle mesure de
sécurité nationale après les violentes
manifestations qui secoue l'archipel
depuis un an
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue en direct sur
rt france pour cette demi heure
d'information l'hydroxyde chloroquine
n'est plus autorisée en france contre le
coc vide 19 le médicament mis en lumière
par le professeur out au début de la
pandémie pouvait être prescrit jusqu'ici
à titre dérogatoire mais le gouvernement
en a décidé autrement après un avis
défavorable du haut conseil de la santé
publique des essais cliniques peuvent
tout de même se poursuivre de son côté
le professeur marseillais fait savoir
qu'il continuerait à soigner avec les
traitements qu'ils estiment les plus
adaptées
lors du conseil des ministres olivier
ferrand a fait part de sa conversation
avec cas didier rahout quand j'ai posé
la question aux professeurs à haute et
je crois qu'il a d'ailleurs répondu
lui-même
hier les manifestants aujourd'hui il ya
quasiment plus le malade donc la
question de la chloroquine et lui
considère que la question la plus rock
il est derrière moi je considère qu'elle
n'est pas derrière nous parce que il
faut pouvoir se tenir prêt et si on
avait un traitement qui pouvait être
efficace et qui avait une augmentation
du nombre de malades qu'on puisse se
réserver la possibilité la possibilité
de le faire maintenant
il ya un cadre réglementaire qui définit
la possibilité ou non de prescrire un
médicament ce médicament dans cette
indication
comme d'autres médicaments dans d'autres
indications si un prescripteur
s'affranchit des règles
il prend entre guillemets ces risques
alors que la france n'autorise plus
l'hydroxyde chloroquine comme traitement
contre le coin vip 19 d'autres pays sont
déterminés à maintenir l'utilisation de
cette molécule et ce malgré les
recommandations au contraire de l'om est
ce les précisions de cyrielle beau et la
controverse autour de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine se poursuit à travers le
monde
aux etats unis l'agencé du médicament
fda a choisi d'autoriser sa prescription
uniquement dans le cadre hospitalier
le traitement à titre préventif pris par
donald trump et lui prescrit alors que
l' oms a annoncé la suspension
temporaire de tous ses essais avec
l'hydro xi chloroquine le président
américain dit avoir arrêté son
traitement
avant cela ce dernier n'a eu de cesse de
défendre son utilisation tout au long de
la pandémie l'hydroxyde chloroquine est
utilisé par des milliers et des milliers
de travailleurs de première ligne pour
qu'ils n'attrapent pas cette horrible
maladie ou peu importe comment vous
la plaie c'est un terrible virus c'est
quelque chose de terrible et beaucoup de
gens l'ont pris beaucoup de médecins
l'ont pris beaucoup de gens ne jure que
par ça est la chloroquine a mauvaise
réputation uniquement parce que j'en
parle je suis donc manifestement un très
mauvais promoteurs
si quelqu'un d'autre en faisait la
promotion on dirait que c'est la
meilleure chose qui soit mais étant
donné que c'est moi coup de tonnerre
également au brésil où le ministère de
la santé a annoncé le maintien de
l'utilisation de ce traitement
malgré les critiques de la communauté
scientifique brésilienne précision
étonnante l' usage de la molécule est
autorisé pour les patients légèrement
atteints à condition d'avoir une
prescription de leur médecin
la demande de chloroquine et très élevés
nous pensons également qu'elle est
efficace
nous avons épuisé le stock nous n'en
avons plus nous essayons de chercher
avec les distributeurs mais c'est
vraiment difficile pour nous d'y
parvenir car la demande pour ce
médicament est immense
malheureusement nous n'avons même pas
besoin de montrer pourquoi nous sommes
de rupture de stock maintien du
traitement également en algérie où aucun
décès lié à l'usagé de cette molécule
n'aurait été enregistrés selon le
président du conseil de l'ordre des
médecins algériens un remède largement
répandue sur le continent africain
notamment au sénégal le pays qui aurait
enregistré des résultats concluants en
milieu hospitalier a confirmé ce
mercredi qu'il allait continuer à
traiter ces malades avec de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine sans émettre d'avis
contraire à son utilisation
le président macky sall prône à nouveau
les mesures de précaution déjà mises en
place au sein du pays nous devons rester
vigilants
nous devons poursuivre l'observance des
gestes barrières pour freiner la
propagation de la maladie
j'ai espoir qu'avec ses efforts continus
d'ici quelques moments nous pourrons
revenir petit à petit à la vie normale
la france est pour le moment le seul
pays d'europe à interdire l'utilisation
de l'hydroxyde chloroquine contre le coc
vide 19 l'essai européen discovery qui
testent actuellement plusieurs
traitements a annoncé avoir arrêté les
inclusions de patients destinée à
prendre ce médicament est pour violaine
guérin immunologiste collective covit 19
l'ex font les médecins à prescrire
l'étude qui a mené
à l'interdiction la chloroquine est
totalement biaisé je pense que si
c'était une été analysé sérieusement par
l'état français il y aurait aucune
raison de d'interdire des drogues sict
eurokin donc je pense qu'il ya des
choses qui nous dépassent et là je
dirais que moi je suis assez centré sur
le soin et que ça va peut-être pétales
rouges justement les journalistes
d'essayer de comprendre ce qui se passe
parce que la situation est tout à fait
surréaliste
l'étude est complètement biaisé lé
groupe ne sont pas comparables elles
émanent d'une base de données de de gens
qui sont essentiellement des
cardiologues et avec des des patients
qui ont des complications cardiaques
importante bien plus que dans la
population un standard on n'arrive pas à
savoir d'ailleurs qu'elle est la liste
des hôpitaux dans la cave
on a récupéré des données les des
scientifiques qu'on fait la publication
n'ont pas vu un seul patient atteint de
deux co vide
il ya beaucoup de choses qui interpelle
en fait l'assemblée approuve la mise en
place de la piste up commis par 338 voix
contre 215 un moyen de traçage numérique
qui divise
de son côté la cnil avait déjà donné son
feu vert pour l application reste la
protège des spect la protection des
données
les précisions de notre reporter thomas
boni l'assurance aura duré plus de
quatre heures et on aura vu des débats
parfois houleux signe que la mise en
place de cette application stop covit
déchaîne les passions au sein de
l'hémicycle
un hémicycle qui s'est finalement
prononcé majoritairement pour 338 voix
pour 215 voix contre la mise en place
donc de cette application censée
combattre la propagation du virus des
débats donc très animées ou des
arguments ont été échangés par les
députés de l'opposition avec ceux de la
majorité et des représentants du
gouvernement qui étaient présents
notamment olivier ferrand qui est exposé
ses arguments lors de son discours
préliminaire il a été quelque peu
chahuté par certains députés je propose
d'écouter mais au nom de quoi
j'empêcherai tel ou tel député telle ou
telle personne de disposer de cet outil
de protection
vous posez des questions vous posez des
questions qui sont totalement légitime
sur le plan éthique
est ce que est ce que cette application
est éthique est ce qu'elle est
liberticide comme l'entente sur les
bancs vous avez liberticide dire
privative de liberté en mon sens je
considère qu empêcher quelqu'un se doter
d'un outil qui permet de se protéger
ça c'est sans doute liberticide ça c'est
un docu partie moi je vais vous dire je
veux avoir la liberté
je veux avoir la liberté demain de
télécharger ou de ne pas télécharger une
application pouvoir de protéger
je veux avoir la liberté de choisir dans
une semaine de l'enlever si je n'en veux
plus je veux avoir la liberté de pouvoir
être au courant avant pour maple que je
suis potentiellement cas contacts et je
veux avoir la liberté de me protéger
on peut en débattre éternellement et
nous sommes là pour ça pas éternellement
mais en débattre
les débats ont essentiellement tourné
autour de la notion de liberté mais pas
seulement question également autour de
la pertinence de la mise en place d'une
telle application n'est-il pas trop tard
pour mettre en place un tel dispositif
un dispositif qui on le rappelle ne sera
pas obligatoire alors certains
s'interrogent sur l'utilité d'une telle
application question également donc
autour de la sécurité des utilisateurs
la ministre de la justice nicole
belloubet s'est voulue rassurante en
expliquant qu'il n'y aurait pas de
fichage pas de géolocalisation et que
cette application était téléchargeable
sur la base du volontariat toutes les
garanties ont été prises pour respecter
la vie privée des français explique
nicole belloubet mais il ya encore des
questions notamment sur l'efficacité
d'une telle mesure je propose d'écouter
jean luc mélenchon député de la france
insoumise et philippe gosselin député
les républicains qui est ce sont tous
les deux prononcés contre
puisqu'on a déjà des outils en nombre
important que l'état le gouvernement
peut déjà travailler réellement et bien
arrêtons la faisons déjà avec les outils
qui sont en notre possession et le cas
échéant tirons-en les bilans et le
moment venu
peut-être faudra-t-il rajouter autre
chose mais pour le moment il me semble
que tout est en ordre
et si on veut continuer à pouvoir le
dire comme on le fait ici en toute
sérénité
eh bien il faut savoir dire stop je fais
partie de ceux qu'ils ne veulent pas
prêt de qui j'étais à moins d'un mètre
pendant plus d'un quart d'heure
je ne veux pas un quart d'heure et moi
d'un mètre c'est le temps d'un baiser de
bien d'autres applications je ne veux
pas ça ne vous regarde pas ni vous qui
pensez que ça ne saura pas quand même
une fois le ministre verront ici
il a dit à mais on ne saura pas un
monsieur virant il vous reste à vivre
davantage pour savoir qu'on finit
toujours par savoir quand on ne veut pas
que ça se sache
malgré une ferme opposition de la part
de certains députés et majorité dans
l'hémicycle la s'est donc prononcé en
faveur de la mise en application de ce
dispositif reste maintenant à passer
l'étape du sénat qui doit se prononcer
ce soir et si le sénat donne son feu
vert alors la mise en place de cette
application stop qu'ovide pourrait
intervenir assez tôt certains parlent
d'une mise en service à partir de ce
week end et loire philippe présentera
demain à 16 heures la phase de lune
déconfinement pour réussir ce dernier le
gouvernement table et on s'en souvient
sur 700 mille tests virologiques par
semaine à partir du 11 mai un objectif
forcément difficile à atteindre alors
combien de tests existe-t-il sur le
marché sont ils tous fiables les
précisions en images
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
à
/
[Musique]
suite
je
[Musique]
un nouveau test de dépistage du
coronavirus devrait être commercialisé
au mois de juin baptisé easy coville a
été mis au point par un consortium
français alexandre à priolo jeune pdg de
skills elle nous explique le déroulement
de ce texte les développements ont été
très rapides en gros on a travaillé deux
mois et demi ce qui est terriblement
cours pour notre industrie
et le résultat c'est le tester bykov qui
est un test salivaire
donc en fait qu'ils n'avaient pas besoin
de vous rendre dans un laboratoire pour
faire le prélèvement la façon dont ça se
passe c'est extrêmement simple on
prélève sous la langue
un peu moins d'un demi-litre de salive
on met cet échantillon successivement
dans deux tubes qui sont chauffés à 65
degrés le tout pendant une heure
et au bout d'une heure on a un résultat
qui est colorimétrique c'est à dire que
si le test est orange orange offre foncé
alors ça veut dire que le test est
négatif
et si le test est jaune vif cela veut
dire que le test est positif
elle s'assure après le déconfinement
progressif le bilan du coronavirus dans
l'hexagone continue de baisser avec 66
nouveaux décès en 24 heures selon les
chiffres de la direction générale de la
santé
au total 28 1596 personnes sont mortes
depuis le début de l'épidémie des
chiffres encourageants mais évidemment
la prudence reste de mise avant les
annonces du premier ministre edouard
philippe qui devrait préciser quels
seront les régions qui passe son verre
et celle qui reste en rouge
la police des police traque les traquent
les sources de mediapart dans le cadre
d'une enquête sur des violences
policières
la journaliste pascale pasquart yellow
avait mis en lumière les zones dont
retour de ré faire le guet une militante
de 73 ans gravement blessée dans une
manifestation fin mars 2019 à nice le
procureur de la ville avait dédouané la
police de toute blessure infligée à la
manifestante elle j'en ai eu mediapart a
été entendu hier comme suspecte par
l'igpn l'objectif des investigations
comprendre qui au sein de
l'administration avait livré des
informations à la presse
et geneviève le gué la militante d'attac
victimes donc de ces violences présumées
l'année dernière passée à nice est
revenu pour nous sur cette journée elle
qui estime que l'igpn ne se focalise pas
assez sur la police dans son enquête
je voudrais dire que parce qu'un pass
carrier lourd c'est une très bonne
journaliste d'investigation puisque la
est arrivé à sortir ce rapport qui en ma
faveur de ce rapport de capitaine de
gendarmerie qui disait que tout était
calme et que qui a refusé d'appliquer
les ordres du commissaire sushi comme
7,7 journalistes elle a fait que son
travail et je vois pas pourquoi l'igpn
l'embêtent à elle au lieu de faire son
travail de de savoir ce que la police
fait parce que normalement l'igpn c'est
pour ces pour enquêter sur les policiers
et pas sur les journalistes je disais
simplement liberté de manifester et je
me suis réveillée de mon état
d'inconscience six heures après à
l'hôpital
alors je pense que ma fracassée par
derrière
j'ai quand même eu un traumatisme
crânien très très grave
et encore aujourd'hui les docteurs me
disent qu'ils ne savent pas comment ça
ce que je suis en vie tellement
tellement c'était un très grave
traumatisme crânien il me reste quand
même des séquelles j'ai l'air comme ça
bien mais je titube et j'ai des
séquelles l'europe
éprouvé par le commis 19 mai pourtant
très divisée
les vingt-sept vont ils réussir à mettre
leur désaccord de côté et accepter le
plan de relance proposé par la
commission européenne aujourd'hui les
précisions de grégoire dos et c'est peu
avant midi que paolo jantzi l'oni le
commissaire européen aux affaires
économiques et monétaires a vendu la
mèche dans un tweet
l'italien a annoncé le montant global
des aides qui seront accordées aux 27
états membres de l'union
la commission propose un fonds de
relance de 750 milliards d'euros en plus
des instruments commun déjà lancé une
percée aux européennes pour faire face à
une crise sans précédent
la présidente de la commission
européenne a appelé l'europe à
outrepasser les divisions au sein de ces
crises et watson a même souri à yann
mettons de côté les vieux préjugés
redécouvrons plutôt les pouvoirs qui est
basé sur l'idée d'une europe commune
la crise à laquelle nous devons faire
face aujourd'hui est énorme mais
l'opportunité pour l'europe est notre
responsabilité sont tout aussi énorme
pour faire ce qu'il faut dans cette
situation et 10 à situation das richtig
surtout l'espagne et l'italie devraient
se partager une grosse part du gâteau
elle la commission européenne prévoyant
d'allouer plus de 40% des fonds rien co2
péninsule la france quant à elle ne
devrait percevoir qu'à peine 39
milliards d'euros un plan immédiatement
soutenue par rome et paris excellent
signal de bruxelles
il va dans la direction indiquée par
l'italie nous avons été décrits comme
des visionnaires parce que nous y avons
cru dès le début 500 milliards d'euros
de subventions et 250 milliards de prêts
est un montant adéquat accélérons les
négociations et des blocs ont les
ressources rapidement j'aurais
essentielle pour l'europe
ursula von der leyen propose un plan de
relance inédit de 750 milliards d'euros
pour les régions et secteurs en
difficulté l'accord franco-allemand a
permis cette avancée
nous devons aller vite et adopter un
accord ambitieux avec tous nos
partenaires européens
le partage de la dette reste un sujet
épineux dans les discussions en effet
les quatre frugaux que sont les pays-bas
l'autriche le danemark et la suède sont
hostiles à l'idée de participer
davantage au budget européen
outre les aides destinées aux pays et
secteurs dans l'urgence le
l'on devrait prévoir des investissements
dans des sphères jugé clés comme le
numérique et la transition verte et pour
que l'eau blanche maison expert en
relations internationales ursula von der
leyen joue gros avec ce plan de relance
maintenant évidemment les choses
sérieuses commencent ce qu'il va falloir
aller vers les états membres et là je
pense que madame von der leyen la hyène
joue gros jeu parce que ou bien ça passe
et à ce moment là elle aura reconnaîtra
comme une véritable femme d'état puisque
c'est l'expression qu'il faut utiliser
ou bien les états membres n'arrivent pas
à se mettre d'accord et à ce moment là
on l'accusera d'avoir vu trop grand et
de ne pas avoir tenu assez suffisamment
compte de l'opinion des états du nord
donc je pense que l a vu son courage de
faire cette proposition aujourd'hui pour
la première fois on utilise le crédit
financier de la commission européenne
pour l'autoriser à faire un gigantesque
emprunt sur les marchés financiers le
secteur aérien en crise dans le monde
entier l'épidémie de kobe de 19 a obligé
de nombreuses compagnies à clouer sa
flotte au sol pendant plus de deux mois
une catastrophe pour les entreprises
dont certaines ont déjà annoncé leur
faillite et précision en images
[Musique]
m
une nouvelle manifestation à hong kong
un important dispositif policier a
dispersé les opposants à pékin réunis
autour du parlement local
ils protestaient contre l'examen d'un
projet de loi criminalisant tout outrage
à l'hymne national chinois
la semaine dernière pékin avait déjà
décidé d'instaurer une nouvelle loi sur
la sécurité dans le territoire les
détails avec françois xavier lambert le
coeur de hong kong à nouveau plongé dans
le chaos sous les yeux des journalistes
les policiers multiplient les tirs de
gaz poivre pour disperser des centaines
de manifestants
les opposants au pouvoir perçu comme
propre et cartes dénonçant projet de loi
criminalisant tout outrage à l'hymne
national chinois au délit qui serait
passible de trois ans de prison
les manifestants se disent déterminés à
faire entendre leurs revendications
les gens ont le droit de manifester et
de venir au rassemblement
donc je pense que c'est vraiment un abus
de pouvoir que de bloquer toutes les
assemblées pacifique et toutes les
demandes de rassemblements ces
manifestations surviennent alors que le
parlement local recommence aujourd'hui
l'examen de ce projet de loi
la situation est suivie attentivement
par les états unis déjà engagés dans une
guerre économique avec la chine des
sénateurs se sont déjà dits prêts à
prendre de nouvelles sanctions contre
pékin
de son côté donald trump a implicitement
menacé la chine de priver au compte de
son statut économique spéciale c'est
quelque chose dont vous allez entendre
parler avant la fin de la semaine de
manière très intense je pense la
pression américaine ne semble pas
atténué la détermination chinoise de
mettre un terme à l'agitation qui secoue
le territoire semi autonome depuis
plusieurs années début mais pékin a
renforcé son influence au parlement hong
kong et des élus proches du gouvernement
chinois ont ainsi pris le contrôle du
comité de la chambre
une commission chargée de passer en
revue les projets de loi avant leur
examen
l'inquiétude des opposants s'est aussi
renforcé la semaine dernière à la suite
de la décision d'imposer à hong kong
nouvelle loi sur la sécurité nationale
officiellement le texte vise à combattre
le terrorisme et
les ingérences étrangères dans le
territoire semi autonome mais il
permettra surtout à pékin d'implanter
légalement sa police secrète à hong kong
le texte devrait être adopté ce jeudi
par l'assemblée nationale populaire
chinoise huawei aminé longue journaliste
consultant pékin a une réelle envie de
faire taire le mouvement aujourd'hui
jusque-là pékin s'était montré
extrêmement comment dire a montré
beaucoup de mansuétude envers le
mouvement démocratique de hong kong est
aujourd'hui on voit qui durcit le ton
que on était surpris même que pékin ne
le fasse pas plus tôt là aujourd'hui on
voit un vrai une véritable volonté de
changement de stratégie et surtout
d'avoir la mainmise sur ces mouvements
le hong kong et les si possible de faire
taire et la libye au coeur de tensions
entre washington et moscou le commandant
en chef des forces armées américaines en
afrique accusé hier la russie d'avoir
déployé des avions de chasse pour
soutenir des mercenaires présent au sol
ces derniers combattent aux côtés du
maréchal khalifa haftar opposants au
gouvernement de tripoli
reconnu par l'onu ces accusations ont
été démenties par moscou qui les
qualifie de fausses nouvelles inventé
par washington et ont fait le point avec
notre correspondant antoine claireaux à
moscou
tout commence avec la publication d'un
communiqué du commandement des états
unis pour l'afrique avec prudence le
document estime que des avions de combat
russes ont été récemment déployé en
libye et fournirait un soutien aérien à
des sociétés militaires privées
sur le terrain les avions en question
serait arrivé depuis la russie bien la
base aérienne russe située en syrie où
il aurait été repeint pour masquer leur
origine les responsables militaires qui
ont ensuite commenté ce communiqué de
presse ne se sont pas embarrassés de
l'emploi du conditionnel ainsi un porte
parole du pentagone affirme sans ambages
que les russes ont envoyé 14 avions
militaires en libye une accusation que
réfute moscou le vice président de la
commission à la défense de la douma
andrik race of a répondu que cette
information je cite ne correspondait pas
à la réalité il au passage rappelé la
position de la russie sur ce dossier
comme quoi moscou appelle à la fin des
effusions de sang en libye et exhorte
toutes les parties au conflit à ne pas
avoir recours aux armes mais plutôt à
s'asseoir à la table des négociations et
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité demain matin 7 heures du
matin heure française
[Musique]
l afrique et compte 1 1 % de cas dans le
monde sait très peu comment vous
l'expliquez nous devons considérer que
les chiffres sont sous-estimés mais nous
ne sommes pas encore au niveau où se
trouve par exemple l'europe ou les états
unis
quelle stratégie vous avez déployés dans
le sud kivu pour limiter la propagation
du virus on a proposé à ce qu'est le
confinement puisse être sélectif est
concerné seulement des personnes âgées à
haut risque de complication pour
sensibiliser la population
ça l'est beaucoup plus facilement
puisque on venait de sortir d'une d'une
épidémie d'ebola qui exige également la
distanciation social lavage des mains
j'étais si on aura affaire à deux
épidémies aussi dangereuse qui est des
mollahs et coronavirus ça pourrait être
très très difficile pour nous chaque
jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de fine
stratégie peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
je suis l'ex maire et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france ici on écoute
ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on me vois pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce qui si c'est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
chez sa mère cette petite boule d'amour
n'aurait aucune chance de survivre dans
la nature
les pandas mères ne peuvent élever qu'un
seul bd à la fois les elle donne
naissance à deux buts chaque année la
chine met beaucoup d'efforts pour
compenser cette erreur cruel de la
nature cela veut dire quels thèmes
vierge elle fait ce sont en chine
l'élevage des pandas effet à la chaîne
c'est comme si on les tire avec une
imprimante 3d pour les présenter au
public par la suite en 2016 le panda a
été retiré de la liste des espèces en
voie de disparition
cette espèce n'est plus menacée mais
reste vulnérable mais tout ce travail de
scientifiques dévoué sera inutile si les
pandas ne peuvent pas se reproduire en
captivité
ce n'est pas qu'ils veulent s'abstenir
les pandas deviennent amoureux avec la
même part est ce qu ils font tout le
reste
cette firmament a donné naissance à des
jumeaux et n'a aucune idée qu'une potion
d'amour spéciale a été formulée juste
pour elle
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
aujourd'hui nous recevons pauline
d'orgeval présidente et cofondatrice de
kohat petit santé une association qui
agit en faveur de l'accès aux soins pour
tous en prenant en compte les besoins
des personnes les plus vulnérables
madame d'hors jeu valable bienvenue sur
arte france ô expliquez nous qui sont
ces personnes vulnérables alors le le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
et c'est vrai que on se rend compte que
les personnes en situation de handicap
notamment ont été largement oublié de
beaucoup de politiques en santé et donc
finissent par renoncer aux soins relance
est allé voir des médecins parce que
rien n'est fait penser pour pouvoir les
accueillir dans de bonnes conditions
voilà donc les personnes fragiles on va
dire que pour répondre à votre question
c'est évidemment les personnes en
situation de handicap quel que soit le
handicap parce qu'il n'ya pas un
handicap
plein de types de handicaps évidemment
possible toutes les personnes en
situation de précarité
parce que souvent elles s'excluent
elle-même